welcome back to the tech savvy software
development week from simply learn it's
day 2 of software development today we
will be discussing algorithms in data
structures
in case if you missed out on day 1 where
we discussed the major fundamentals and
foundations of software development the
data structures then please feel free to
check out the cards above or we'd also
leave a link in the description box
below to all our videos or playlists
coming into the topic algorithms happen
to be the brains of any software program
you develop it happens to be a
programmer's baby steps to device a
solution to the problem in a
step-by-step manner algorithms are the
main logical backbone of any software
development for example consider maps
for navigation that you use on your
smart devices
we use several algorithms like daishra's
algorithm breadth first search depth
first search and many more to find the
shortest and most feasible path to
travel from source to the destination we
have just scratched the surface and
there's a whole mountain of algorithms
we'll learn all of those in detail with
practical implementation in detail so
stay tuned to us now over to our experts
let's get started
so we will begin this data structure
part two from where we left the data
structures part one that is trees and
data structures
so followed by trees in data structures
we will be learning the tree traversal
in data structures then we will go
through binary trees binary search trees
and then we will enter recursion and
after finishing recursion we will begin
with avl trees then we will continue
with
b trees and b plus trees
followed by b plus trees we have the
sorting algorithms so we will begin with
bubble sort then we will go through
insertion sort then we have selection
sort followed by that we have heap sort
then the merge sort quick sort bucket
sort and counting sort algorithms moving
ahead we have the radix sort followed by
the sorting algorithms we enter into
graphs
and after learning the fundamentals and
some examples in graphs we will continue
with kriskel's algorithm then the
backtracking algorithm then we have the
spanning trees understanding the
spanning trees we will go through some
breadth first search and depth first
search algorithms which are used for
exploring the nodes entries then we have
shell sort then the greedy algorithm and
finally we have the prim's algorithm
so i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now without any further ado let's
get started with the first concept in
the data structures part two that is
trees what is a tree data structure
so what exactly is a tree data structure
the tree is a non-linear data structure
that consists of nodes and is connected
by edges i know it's a little difficult
to understand just by the definition so
let me show you the pictorial
representation
as you can see we have the elements that
is 10 20 30 40 50 60 and 70 and all
these are stored in the tree data
structure they are stored in a
non-linear structure if we had used
arrays it would have been in a linear
consecutive way where 10 starts first
and 70 ends at the last position
now in the next section we will discuss
why we had made to a switch to the tree
data structure when we already had a
linear data structure that is airy
now the next topic that is why we need
three data structure
so there are many reasons why we have
switched into tree data structure and
one of the reason is a linear data
structure always stores the elements in
a sequential form that is one after the
other and in operations to be performed
in linear data structure
the time complexity increases as the
data size increases
you can see here that as discussed
before the elements are stored in a
linear form that is 10 at the first
place and 70 at the last place imagine
you wanted to access the element 70 then
using the traversal you had to start
from
the first position that is 10 20 30 40
and slowly at the end is 70. so
accessing that particular element is
really time consuming we are facing this
just for 70 elements imagine if we had
700 elements
right so that is exactly why we had made
a switch to tree data structure and
using tree data structure we have many
advantages as the tree data structure is
completely non-linear and it allows
easier access and quicker access of the
data elements how is that possible we
will look into it into the next segment
where we will discuss about the
traversal of trees
now before we understand the traversal
of trees we should understand another
important topic that has the
terminologies of tree
so the first one is the node node is the
entity that contains the keys and
pointer to its child nodes
so here you can see that the elements a
b c d e f and g are the elements so each
and every element or the blue dot is
called as unknown and the blue dots here
are
one two three four five six and seven so
we have seven blue dots so we have seven
elements here so you can see the line
between each elements right so this
particular line is called edge now we'll
discuss about the edge in the next part
so the connecting links between any two
nodes are called as edges so we
discussed about the nodes right where
the element is stored the blue dots are
the nodes and the lines connecting
between the elements or nodes is called
as the edge
so out of all the nodes
this first node that is the element a is
called as the root node in a tree data
structure
so indirectly root node is also called
as the parent node of all the nodes now
we will understand what are parent nodes
and children nodes
so in the tree data structure the node
that is the node's predecessor is called
as parent node so here we have discussed
that a or the root node is the parent of
all nodes
so for a b and c nodes are children
nodes and for b and c nodes a happens to
be the parent node similarly
d and e are the children nodes of b and
f and j are children nodes of c
and
the
nodes d and e have b as the parent node
and the nodes f and g have c as the
parent node now followed by that
we will understand the descendant node
so as discussed before the descendant
node is the node that comes after the
parent node here the b and c are the
descendants of a and d and e are
descendants of b and similarly f and g
are the descendants or children of the
node c
so in a tree data structure the node
which does not have any child is called
as the leaf node now at the end we have
d
e f and g so these particular nodes do
not have any children nodes like b and c
so these particular four nodes which do
not have any children are called as the
leaf
nodes in a tree data structure the node
with at least one child node is called
as the internal node
so here the internal nodes are b and c
which have at least one child
in a tree the total number of children
of a node are called as the degree of
that node so in this particular diagram
the degree of root node is 2 because it
has two child nodes and the degree of b
is 2 as it has two child nodes similarly
the degree of c is 2 because it has two
child nodes but when it comes to d e f
and g
the
degree is 0 because they do not have any
child nodes
in a tree data structure the root node
is said to be at level 0 and the
children of the root node are said to be
at level 1 and the children nodes of the
level 1 are at level 2. so to understand
this let's go through the diagram as you
can see this particular root node is
called as level zero
and followed by that we have the
children nodes of a that is b and c and
that level is called as level one and
followed by that we have level two and
if this tree goes forward the levels
also increase accordingly
now in a tree data structure the total
number of edges from a leaf node to the
particular node is the longest path and
this particular path is called as the
height of that node
now here we have our general tree data
structure and here you can see the
height of node a s2
and the height of node b and c together
is at 1 and the height of the last leaf
nodes happens to be 0.
next in the tree data structure the
total number of edges from the root node
to a particular node is called as the
depth of that node now in this
particular tree data structure the depth
of the root node is 0 and the depth of b
and c together is 1 because the number
of edges connecting to the
node a from b is just one and similarly
the number of edges connecting the node
c from a is just one so the depth of
both b and c is one
now if we consider the last leaf nodes
then the depth is two because if you see
g is connected to a using two different
edges similarly f is connected to a
using two different edges and e and d
also have two nodes to connect to a so
the depth is 2
now in the next segment we will
understand the tree node
so the tree data structure has data part
and references to its left and right
child node in the tree data structure so
here you can see this is the node and
the node has three segments that is data
element and the references to its left
child and the references to its right
child
now there are four different types of
trees the first one is the binary tree
followed by that we have the binary
search tree then we have avl tree and
finally we have the b3 let us discuss
each one of them the first one is the
binary tree a binary tree is a tree data
structure in which each parent node at
most has two children
so in this particular tree we'll have at
most two children that means it might
have one or more than one but not more
than two children per node
moving ahead we have the binary search
tree so a binary search tree or a bst is
a tree data structure in which each node
has a maximum of two children all nodes
of the left sub tree are less than the
right node all nodes on the right sub
tree are more than the root node so here
you can see the image or the gif which
represents the image of a binary search
tree so here all the nodes of the left
sub tree are less than the root node and
all the nodes of the right subtree are
more than the root node
the next type of the tree is the avl
tree the avl tree got its name after
inventory georgie adelson welsky and
landis
avl tree is the self-balancing tree in
which each node maintains a balanced
factor most value is either one
zero or minus one
balance factor is equals to height of
the left subtree minus height of the
right subtree or height of the right
subtree minus height of the left subtree
so in this particular image you can
identify
it is an avl tree
and now the last type of tree that is
the b tree
b3 is a special kind of self-balancing
search tree in which each node can
contain more than one key and can have
more than two children b3 is also known
as the height balanced m v tree now in
this particular gif we can see how a b
tree looks like
now followed by this we will discuss the
tree traversal
so traversing a tree helps to visit
required node in the tree to perform
specific operations tree traversal can
be performed in three different ways
the first one is the pre-order traversal
where we visit the node
and visit all the node from the left
side then visit all the nodes from the
right side so this particular gif is an
example for pre-order traversal where we
visit all the left side nodes first then
we visit the right side notes
now we will move ahead into the next
type of traversal
that is the in order traversal
first we visit all the nodes from the
left side then we visit the root node
and then represent all the nodes from
the right side so this particular gif
will be an example for the in order
traversal where we visit all the left
side nodes and then we visit the root
node and followed by that we will visit
the right side nodes and the last type
of traversal is the post order traversal
where we visit all the nodes from the
left side first then revisit all the
nodes from the right side and finally
visit the root node
so this particular image on the right
side is an example for post order
traversal now before we get into
learning the applications of trees we
will try to execute one example based on
the post order pre-order and in order
traversals entry data structure so you
can see that we have an example on my
screen right now so here we have the
node structure
then we have the in order traversal
function followed by that we have the
pre-order traversal function and finally
we have the post order traversal
function now let's quickly run this
program and see the output and don't
worry about the code this particular
code document will be attached in the
description box below and you can have
access to it
now we have the run option over here and
the program got successfully executed uh
you can ignore this warning and here we
have the in order traversal of the tree
and the first output then we have the
pre-order traversal of the tree and
finally we have the post order traversal
of the tree now let's discuss the last
part
where we will learn the application of
trees
so the application of trees are as
follows binary search trees are used to
quickly check whether an element is
present in the set or not then we have
the most popular database usage of b3
which is a variant of tree data
structure then we have the modified
version of trees called as tris which is
used in the router to store routing
information and finally the compiler
uses a syntax tree to validate the
syntax of every program you write what
is tree traversal in data structure
tree traversal is a process of visiting
each and every node in a tree data
structure
so right here on my screen we have a
tree with different nodes that is a
b
c
d
and e
so here we will be visiting all the
nodes one after the other using the tree
traversal methods
now that we have a brief understanding
of what exactly is a tree traversal
process let's get into the next topic of
our discussion for today that is
the data structure used for free
traversal
in a tree data structure there are
primarily two data structures utilized
for tree traversal the first one is the
stack data structure and the second one
is the queue data structure a stack is a
linear data structure that operates on
the last in first out lifo principle
there is only one pointer in the stack
that is the top pointer which points to
the stack's topmost element only the top
of the stack is used for insertion and
deletion now the next one is the queue
a queue unlike stacks is open on both
the ends the one end is always open and
used only for input and the other is
only used for deletion or elimination
the principle followed in queue is
first in first out or fifo approach
followed by that we will look into the
different types of tree traversals in
data structure
tree traversal can be done in the
following ways the first one is breadth
first search and the second one is the
depth first search
first let us have a look at the breadth
first search algorithm or breadth first
search traversal
we follow level order traversal in
breadth first search breadth first
search traverses notes by level instead
of subtrees first we visit the root node
followed by the root node we visit the
left sub tree of the tree then followed
by the left sub tree we finish the right
subtree of the entire tree
after that we go until the leaf notes of
the entire tree is found the second one
is the depth first search in depth first
search we traverse three data structure
in three ways that is pre-order
traversal in-order traversal and
post-order traversal
let us take a look at how these
traversals are carried out
first let us discuss the pre-order
traversal
we traverse the root node first in the
pre-order traversal then we traverse
through the left sub tree and finally we
traverse through the right sub-tree
then there is in-order traversal in
order traversal involves traversing of
the left sub tree first followed by that
we enter the root node then we visit the
right subtree lastly we have the post
order traversal so post order traversal
involves traversing of left subtree
first then the right subtree and finally
we visit the root node
now next we will have a look at some of
the important applications of tree
traversal in data structure
so we use tree traversal in data
structures to build a prefix expression
or polish notation from expression trees
then utilize the pre-order traversal and
then traverse the expression tree in a
pre-orderly manner
a binary tree's postfix representation
or reverse polish notation can be
generated using post-order traversal
because it returns values from the
underlying set in order according to the
comparator setting up the binary search
tree in order traversal is often
employed on binary search trees
a complete binary tree can be deleted or
released when deleting or freezing nodes
and values in the post order traversal
now next we will see an example based on
trade reversal in data structures
so on my screen we have an example for
tree traversal in data structure to
begin we have included the enum or user
specified data type traversal it mostly
used to give integral constant names
which make a programmer easier to
comprehend and maintain
we defined three variables in the enum
data type that is pre-order in order and
post order traversal we can define the
type that can take one of the two values
by using the typedef and enum keywords
we have a traversal data type with trap
variable and a node data type with node
variable then we define the node using
the data structure type as struct node
we declare one variable x and two nodes
as a left and right nodes respectively
in this node section
we then attempted to create node using
the create node function passing the
root node as an argument in this code we
use a malloc function to create a node
assign data to x and null to both the
right and left nodes before returning to
the root node
if node t is not equal to null we simply
return it otherwise we will use the
released tree function to release the
left and right nodes and if neither is a
root node then we will use the free
function to release the node t which
will behave as the root node
then we define the display tree function
which takes the trap variable and the
root node as parameters
there is a condition in this function
that is if the root node is not null we
will return the root node then using the
switch case scenario we attempted to
traverse the tree using all three types
of traversals
we utilize a trav variable in the switch
function so if any of the in-order
pre-order or post-order variables match
the trap variable the traversal will be
executed then we created a tree using
the create tree function which takes a
data variable as input in the create
tree function we used a malloc function
to create the root node and we first
assigned a null to the left and right
nodes as well as the data to the
variable x before returning to the root
node
we first traverse the root node then the
left subtree and finally the right
subtree in the pre-order traversal case
in order traversal case we first
traverse the left subtree then the root
node and finally the right subtree and
in the post-order traversal case v
traverse the left sub tree then the
right subtree and finally traverse
through the root node
and finally we exit the display tree
function and move on to the main
function we assign the values 5 as the
root node then 10 20 and 30 as the left
notes and similarly 15 25 and 35 as the
right notes and then we call the three
tree traversals that is preorder in
order and post order to traverse the
tree and finally we release the root
mode now let us try to execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that the output has been displayed on my
screen so the pre-order traversal is 5
10 20 25 15 30 and 35
followed by the pre-order traversal we
have the in-order traversal that is 20
10 25 5 30 15 and 35 and finally we have
the post order traversal that is 20 25
10 30 35 15 and 5
and with that let me give you a simple
question
so what is the pre-order and post order
traversal of this binary search tree so
the elements are one two three four five
six and seven you need to find out the
pre-order and post-order traversal of
this binary tree and you can let us know
the answer in the comment sections below
what exactly is a binary tree
so it is a treated structure in which
each node can have at most two child
nodes these nodes are referred to as
left child node and right child node
next let's discuss about some terms
related to binary tree
first up a node a node consists of data
and a link to its both child nodes
next the root node root node is the
first node of the tree next leaf nodes
these are the nodes which has no child
next parent node apart from the root
node any node which has at least one
child is called as parent to that child
node next up a child node any node with
a parent is called as a child node
next up is the internal node any node
with a child and a parent is called as
an internal node next up is the height
of the binary tree the longest path from
the root to any leaf node is called as
the height of the binary tree
next up is the depth of the binary tree
the depth of the node is the total
number of edges from the root node to
the target node or the
last child node
now let's try to implement the binary
tree in the code editor
as you can see now we are on the code
editor and the code on my screen is an
example for binary tree now here you can
see that we have created a structure for
node followed by that we have a function
where we will print the tree
and this is our main function
now don't worry about the code this
particular code segment will be
available in our description box below
and you can always have access to it and
try to edit and run this code on your
own local system to have a better
learning experience now without further
ado let's try to run this program
quickly and see the output
so there you go the code got
successfully executed and here you can
see the output of this particular binary
tree
now let's get back to the theory part
so as discussed before followed by the
implementation part we will learn about
the properties of a binary tree
now let's discuss the properties of the
binary trees
first up maximum number of nodes at a
level l is 2 to the power l
next up maximum number of nodes in a
binary tree of height h is equals to 2
to the power of h minus 1.
next up minimum possible height in a
binary tree with two nodes is equals to
log of l plus 1 base 2.
next up the minimum possible level in a
binary tree with n nodes is equals to
log of l plus 1 base 2.
finally a binary tree with l leaves has
at least
log l base 2 plus 1 levels
now
let's discuss about the different types
of binary trees
first up we have the full binary tree
followed by that we have the complete
binary tree
then we have the perfect binary tree
followed by that we have the balanced
binary tree and lastly the degenerate
binary tree let's discuss about these in
detail first up full binary tree a full
binary tree is a unique tree data
structure in which a node can have
either two children or no child
next a complete binary tree
so a complete binary tree is another
specific binary tree where each node on
all levels except the last level must
have two children and at the lowest
level all leaves should reside possibly
on the left side
the next one is the perfect binary tree
a binary tree is perfect if every node
must have two children and every leaf is
on the same level
the next one is called as the balanced
binary tree
a binary tree is balanced if for each
node the height of the left sub tree and
the height of the right subtree varies
at most by just one
at last we have the degenerate binary
tree
a binary tree is said to be degenerate
if every internal node has only one
child
we have now discussed the binary tree
some terms and properties related to
binary trees and types of binary trees
now we will look into the operations
that needs to be performed on the binary
tree so there are basically three types
of operations that can be performed on
binary tree which are traversal
insertion and deletion
so first we'll look into the traversal
operations
there are three different types of
traversal operations possible on binary
tree which are pre-order traversal
in order traversal and finally the post
order traversal
now let's get back into the text editor
mode and try to execute our example
so right now we are on the text editor
and this particular code is for the
traversal operations on our
binary tree and here you can see we have
the structure for node and we have also
the in order function
pre-order function and post order
function don't worry about the code this
particular code will be available in the
description box below and after you have
written the code we have some standard
input over here you can see that we are
giving the number of edges as four and
the left subtree elements are two and
one and the right subtree elements are
two and three and another left subtree
elements are
three and five and lastly we have five
and six for another left subtree
now let's try to execute this code
now we have already executed the code
and we also have the output over here
and here you can see we have entered the
number of edges as four and the
traversal is in order traversal which is
one two six five and three and the
pre-order traversal output is two
1 3 5 6 and the post order traversal is
1 6 5 3 and 2. now let's get back to the
ppt now we have the insertion operation
and now let's get back to our text
editor and try to see an example for
insertion operation as well
so on my screen you can see an example
for insertion operation
so here we have the insert function
as i said this particular code will be
available
in the description box below now let's
provide the standard input
so the standard input will be four edges
and we have two and one as the left
subtree and two and three as right
subtree three and five as left subtree
again and five and six as the left
subtree now let's quickly run this code
and there you go the program got
successfully executed and here we have
the
output
the nodes got inserted and it has
provided an in order traversal that is
one two six five and three
now let's get back to the presentation
and the last type of operation is the
deletion operation let's quickly execute
an example based on deletion operation
as well
now as you can see we are on the text
editor again now here the example is for
deletion operation we have the delete
function over here
now for this particular program we don't
need any standard inputs so just let's
run the program
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
output over here and in order traversal
before deletion and in order traversal
after the deletion of an element
so the deleted element is element 11.
now with that let's get back to the
presentation mode again so that's how
the element got deleted now we have
reached to the last part of this session
that happens to be the final key take
aways
so what are the final takeaways so
binary tree is faster at search
operations than other type of tree and
it is easier to find maximum and minimum
elements in the binary tree binary tree
does not allow duplicate values and
graph traversal is done using binary
tree it is used to convert the post
fixed expressions into the prefix
expressions let's get started with
introduction to binary search tree
binaries history is a set of nodes
organized in such a manner that they all
have the same binary search tree
characteristics
a key and a value is assigned to each
node
the requested key is compared to the
keys in binary search tree so during
search if the key is found then the
corresponding value
will be retrieved
next up
properties of binary search tree
first up
the left sub tree of a node contains
only nodes with keys lesser than the
parent node
next up
the right sub tree of a node contains
only nodes that are greater than the
parent node
the left and the right subtree each must
also be a binary search tree
next let's discuss what are the
operations we can perform on a
binary search tree
first up insertion
last deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we can insert a node in a such a way so
that we obey binary search tree rules
that is the
new node should be either less than the
parent node if it's a it's on the left
subtree or if it's on the right subtree
it should be greater than the parent
node let's execute this in the code
editor
we will start by creating a class for
the binary search tree
so class
pst
print data
and bst pointers
left
comma
right
next we will define some functions
publicly
public
first default constructor
and a parameterized constructor
a function to insert the value
and a function to traverse the node
now let's write default constructors
definition
so bst
pst
now let's write the parameterized
constructors definition
bst
and
value
data
is equals to value
and left
is equals to null
and
right
to null
now let's write the definition for the
insert function
so bst
bsd
star
root
comma
end
value
now we will check if the tree is empty
or not
so if
root
then we will insert the first node
we will return
new
pst
value
otherwise we will insert the data so if
the value
is greater than
root
data
and
then we have to insert it
in the right subtree
so
root
right
is equals to
insert
root
right
comma
value
else
also the value should be inserted in the
left
side
so root
left
is equals to
insert
root left
comma value
and then we will return
root
now let's write the traverse function
so
void pst
drivers
pst
star route
f
root
and we will return
otherwise we will first traverse
left side
then we will print the root data
and then we will traverse
the right side
root
right
now let's write the main block
so we will start with an empty tree so
bst
b
comma star root
is equals to
null
root
is equals to
b dot insert
root
comma
50
d dot
insert
equals to
root comma 10.
b dot insert
gonna be root comma
30
d dot insert
sorry we already use 50 so we will use
60
a dot insert
root
comma
let's use 20
let's try to traverse this
so b dot
traverse
route
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created and traversed our first binary
search tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following the
binary search tree rules that is the
value of the left subtree should be less
than the parent node and the value of
the right subtree should be greater than
the parent node
let's try these in the code editor
let's start by creating a node
this time we will use structure so
struct
so
node
star left
comma
star
right now we will create a utility
function to create a new binary search
tree node
substruct
node
star
new node
and
item
equals to
product
star
malloc
size of
product
node
next
amp
will be assigned the key
is equals to item
amp
left
equals to null
and
temp
right
is equals to
null
now let's write
a function to traverse the tree
traverse
node
star
root
so if
root
is equals to null
traverse
root
left
see out
root
e
traverse
route
right
now let's write a utility function to
insert the new node with the given key
in the binary search tree
so substruct
star
insert
key
so if
node
is equals to null
then we will return
new node
key
we will recur down the tree so if
e
is less than
the node key
then we will
insert in the left subtree so node
left
is equals to insert
code
left
comma
key
else
node right
should be inserting
now let's return the node
now we have given a non-empty binary
search tree
so we have to return the node with the
minimum key value found in that tree
so
we will start
out star mode
product
node
star
current
is equal to node
so we will loop down to find the left
most leaves
so
while
current
and
parents left
is not equals to null
so current
should be equals to
current
return
current
delete node
product
node star
loop
comma
and
key
f
root
equals to null
return
route
now if the key to be related is smaller
than the roots key then it lies in the
left subtree so we will check
if
e
less than
root key
then root
left
it will be equals to
delete
node
root
left key
comma key
now if the key is deleted
is greater than the roots key then it
lies in the right subtree so else
if
e
is greater than root
root
right
is equals to
delete
node
root
right
comma okay
else
if
roots
dot left
equals to null
and
root
dot right
is equals to null
and return
else
have
root
that
equals to null
then
struct node
star
is equal to
root
right
and free
route
return temp
else if
roots
right
is equals null
then struct
is equal to root
three
route
return
amp
now note with the two children get the
inorder successor
smallest in the right subtree
so struct
node
star
temp
is equals to
min value
node
root
right
now we will copy the inorder successors
content to this node so root
is equals to temp
now we will delete the in order
successor so root
right
first to
delete
node
root right
comma
temp
now we will return
root
now let's write the main block
we will start with an empty tree
note
star
route
is equal to
null
now root is equals to
insert
root comma
2
root
is equals to insert
root
comma five
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
3
root
is equals to insert
root
comma 4
root
is equals
to
insert
root comma
7
and root
equals to insert
root comma
6
let's try to traverse this so c out
traversal
of
the given
ours
root
now first we will delete a value c out
delete
to
our root is equals to
delete node
root comma
two
see out
traversal
after
deleting
traverse
route
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
deleted
to and traverse the tree again
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up left side nodes are always
lesser than the parents node and the
right side node are always more than the
parent node
next it is easier to search and sort
elements in a binary search tree
finally a binary search tree offers
faster insertion and deletion operations
what is recursion
well recursion is a process in which a
function repeatedly calls itself either
directly or indirectly those calls are
majorly done by explicitly calling
function by its name however it can also
be accomplished by implicit calling as
well the fundamental idea behind calling
the function over and over again is to
break a larger problem into smaller sub
problems
we do this for reducing the
computational complexity of a larger
problem by breaking it into several
pieces this tactic is also called as
divide and conquer approach in
programming so now you must be thinking
about how we can break the larger
problem into smaller sub problems
well to do that we break the given
problem statement into two parts the
first one is base case and the second
one is recursive step
the base case is nothing but the
simplest instance of a problem that
consists of condition which holds the
recursive function
given the function calls argument this
base case computes the output of our
program right away whereas in the
recursive step we compute the result
using one or more recursive calls to the
same function but with the inputs
decrease in size or complexity
to understand this breakdown
let's have a look at mathematical aspect
of recursion
suppose you have to formulate a
mathematical function for computing the
sum of n natural numbers that means the
function that you are going to create
must calculate the summation of all
natural numbers in the range 0 to n
mathematically it can be represented as
summation of all numbers from k is equal
to 0 to k is equal to n
now the critical question here is how
can we actually represent this in form
of recursive function
the answer is quite simple all we need
to do is break this larger problem into
small fragments we can represent this
problem as n plus sum of all natural
numbers till n minus 1
this process of traversing in function f
n minus 1 times is called the recursive
step of our problem statement
whereas the base case is a condition
which is stopping the recursion when k
is reaching value 0
in terms of programming it can be
represented using a vlog now i hope you
guys have understood how we can break a
larger problem into smaller sub problems
moving further we are going to
understand how recursion gets executed
in memory area
in order to do that we'll take this c
program as an example in this program we
have two methods the main method
contains one variable and the statement
that invokes a function name fun
this function fun is making a recursive
call in its function body we have both
base case and recursive step inside this
function's body
now whenever a function is called its
activation record will be maintained
inside the stack
so for this program we are going to look
into its control flow
as we know the main function gets
invoked primarily by an operating system
thus will include the main function at
first in our memory stack this
activation record will consist of local
variables of function parameters and the
record of return address to the caller
but here for the sake of simplicity we
are just maintaining the local variables
inside the activation record after this
step as you can see the main function is
activating method 1 with argument 3.
once activated it will prompt 3 on
screen and will invoke fund 3-1 that is
fun2 now again as 2 is greater than 0
the control will invoke fund 2-1 that is
fun1 after this the control will
activate fund 0.
this time once the control enters an f
lock it will execute a return statement
and activation record 0 will get popped
out of the memory stack
further every function inside the memory
stack will get popped out from it which
will result in generation of output the
output that will get printed on the
console for this particular program is
three two one
now here is the interesting question
that we want you all to answer
based on the properties of recursion
that we have discussed till now which of
the following statements seems right to
you the options that we have are
recursion is always better than
iteration option b
recursion uses more memory compared to
titration
option c recursion uses less memory
compared to the iteration
it will be interesting to see how many
of you guys will get this right so guys
do leave your answers to this question
in comment section below in a week's
time we'll be announcing the right
answer and you all can check it out now
moving ahead we'll discuss different
types of recursion in programming
there are basically four types of
recursion the first one is direct
recursion the second one is indirect
recursion the third one is tail
recursion and the fourth one is non-tail
recursion so let's discuss direct
recursion
a function is called direct recursive if
it calls itself in its function body
over and over again
to better understand this definition
let's look at the structure of a program
that is direct recursive in nature
in this program we have a method named
fun which is calling itself again and
again in its function body thus we can
say that it is direct recursive in
nature
next up is indirect recursion
the recursion in which the function
calls itself where another function is
called as indirect recursion
for example in this program you can
clearly see that the function fun one is
explicitly calling fun2 which is
invoking fun1 again explicitly hence we
can say that this is an example of
indirect recursion
further we have tail recursion
a recursive function is said to be tail
recursive if the recursive call is the
last execution done by the function
let's try to understand this definition
with the help of an example
if you observe this program you can see
that the last line adi will execute for
method fun is recursive call and because
of that there is no need to remember any
previous state of our program
finally we have a non-tail recursive
function on our list
a recursive function is said to be
non-tell recursive if the recursion call
is not the last thing done by the
function
after returning back there is something
left to evaluate let's consider one
example
in this function you can clearly observe
that there is another operation after
the recursive call hence our adi will
have to memorize the previous state
inside this memory block that is why
this program can be considered as
non-tail recursive
now finally let's implement a program to
demonstrate the recursion
the program that we are going to
implement is solution to the problem
statement that we discussed earlier
according to that problem statement we
have to calculate the sum of n natural
numbers given the number n
now in order to address this problem we
are going to use c programming language
so without any further ado let's head
over to the code editor
now in order to get started with coding
implementation first we'll create an
utility function to calculate sum of n
natural numbers so let's do that
and we'll pass an argument and
n
now we have arrived inside the body of
function sum what we'll first do is
we'll calculate sum of n minus 1 natural
numbers by making and recursive call to
function sum so let's do that
sum
n minus 1 and we'll store this value
inside a temporary variable
now we'll add this temporary variable's
value
to n in order to return it as an result
the statements that we just wrote are
called as recursive steps but if you
observe this statement
we are not putting any limitation to our
recursive call so that is why we'll have
to add base case to our function so
let's do that
f
n equal to equal to zero
then
return
zero
with this we have successfully
implemented a sum function
so let's work on our driver method to
generate the result
and this driver method
first will create a variable n
and after that we'll write a printf
statement
enter
the natural
number
n
to calculate
the sum of
n numbers
semicolon
and in next line we'll write scanf
statement in order to take input from
our user so
inside this will write modulus d comma
ambrose in n
and semicolon
and the next statement will make a call
to a sum function in order to calculate
sum of n natural numbers so how we can
do that well we can add modulus d here
comma
sum
and
semicolon
and i hope
our code works fine now so let's check
it
by compiling
here
the console is asking us to provide with
value of variable n and i am going to
provide value 5 here so let's provide
value 5.
and enter
so
the output that we are getting is 15
here that means a code works fine
recursion it is one of those topics
which tends to blend with almost every
other category
in the programming world
interviewers always ask questions based
on recursion to gauge candidates problem
solving abilities
because this topic pushes the
candidate's limit and differentiate them
between good and exceptional
in this session we will discuss some of
the commonly used recursion problems
asked in the interviews
we will calculate the sum of numbers
from 0 to a given number
we will start with creating a function
sum
in function definition we will first
check if the given number is 0
or 1
then we will return the number else we
will return addition of that number with
the recursive sum function
with n minus 1 as an argument
now let's try it in the code editor
we will write a function int
sum
argument and num
we will check
if
num
is equals to 0
or
num
is equals to 1
if yes then we will return
num
else
we will return
num
plus
sum
of
n minus 1.
now
we will write the code for the main
block
we will declare end and comma press
we will call cn
to take the input data
then we will equals res equals to
sum
at
n
we will print this sum
yes
now let's try and execute this program
we will give argument as 5
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly
let's get back to our slides
now let's move on to our next question
we will discuss a recursive function to
find the factorial of given number
we will start with creating a function
fact
in function definition we will first
check if the given number is less than
or equal to
1
then we will return 1 else we will
return multiplication of that number
with a recursive fact function call with
n minus 1 as an argument
now let's try that in a coordinator we
will start with function and
fact
argument end
and
if
n is less than equals to 1
then
we will
return 1
else
we will return
and multiplied by recursive function
at
with n minus 1 as argument
now let's write the code for the main
block
so we will declare variables end
and comma res
will take input
from the
user
now rest is equals to
fact
and
now we will try to print the value of
res
so
factorial
yes
let's try and execute this
we will find the factorial of 5 which is
120
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly it is getting us the value of
factorial 5 which is
let's get back to our slides if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
then we will move on to our next
question
we will discuss a recursive function to
find the nth fibonacci number
we will start with creating a function
fibonacci
in this function's definition we will
first check if the given number is less
than or equal to 1
then we will return that number
else we will return the sum of recursive
function fibonacci with n minus 1 as an
argument and recursive function
fibonacci with n minus 2 as an argument
now let's try to do that in the code
editor
let's start by creating a function
and fibo
with argument as
and n
we will first check if n is less than
equals to 1.
if yes then we will return
and
otherwise we will return
sum of
recursive function fivo
at n minus 1
and the fibonacci function
at n minus 2.
write code for the main block
we will start with variable
end
and
comma
res
we will call cn function to get user
value for n
then we will store the value of
fibonacci function in res
now we will call print function say out
to print the value of rs
so a net fibonacci
remember
equals to res
return
zero
let's try and execute this
we will check the fibonacci number at
ninth position which is 34.
as you can see we are getting the value
as 34 that is our function is working
flawlessly
let's get back to our slides
now we will move forward with our next
question
we will be discussing a recursive
function that can check if a string is
palindrome or not
we will start with creating a boolean
function in is parallel
with an argument as string str
integer low
and integer high
first we will check if the string has at
least one character or not
then we will compare the first character
and the last character
if a mismatch happen then we will return
false otherwise we will move to our next
pair by recalling the recursive function
with incrementing low and decrementing
high by 1.
now let's try this in the code editor we
will start by creating a recursive
function to check if str
from low to high is a palindrome or not
here the low defines the
first index and high defined the last
index
so we will write a boolean function
is
valence
with argument as
string
str
we will check for star base gas
so if
low is greater than equals to high
then we will return
now we will check
if
the first character
is
equal
to the last character
and false
now we will move to the next pair
so
return
is
palin
with argument as str comma
low
plus 1
comma hi
minus 1.
now let's write the code for the main
block
so
we will take string
sdr is equals to
malayalam
now we will check if
alien
now we will find the length of this
string so int
alien
is equals to
str
dot length
now we will check
if
is palin
from str comma zero
to comma
lin
minus one
if it is true then it will
give c out
we will print palindrome
syndrome
else
we will print
not
a palindrome
let's try and execute this in the code
editor
as you can see it is saying that it is a
palindrome which is correct so a
function is working flawlessly let's get
back to our slides
finally we will discuss a recursive
function that can reverse a given string
we will start by with creating a
function reverse
with an argument as string str integer
low and integer high
first we will check if the string is
greater than one character or not
if yes then we will swap them
then we will move to our next pair by
calling the recursive function reverse
with incrementing low and decrementing
high by one
now let's try this code in the code
editor
we will start with creating a recursive
function but before that
we will include a special library
include
algorithm
now
void
reverse
string
ampersand str
note that we have passed the string as a
reference parameter
low
end
high
now we will check if
low
is less than
high
if yes then we will swap
str
at
low comma
str
at high
then we will call the recursive function
reverse
to move to our next pair
str
comma
low plus 1
comma hi
minus 1
let's write code for the main block
we will write string
str
which is equals to
simply learn
now we will reverse
sdr
comma zero
comma
str dot
length minus one
now
see out
reverse
of the string
sdr
is equals to
let's try and execute this
as you can see this function is working
flawlessly as it has reversed the word
simpler
an avl tree is a height balanced binary
search tree for each node we have to
make sure that the height of the left
subtree and the right substrate can
differ by at most one we can calculate
this balance factor by subtracting the
height of the left sub tree from the
height of the right subtree
now let's discuss various rotations we
can perform on avl trees
first up ll rotation next are our
rotations next lr rotation
at last rl rotation
let's discuss them in detail
first up ll rotation
it is a clockwise rotation when a node
is inserted on the left subtree of the
left subtree of a node then we apply
this rotation to balance the tree it is
applied on the node below the balance
factor 2 node that is we will apply
write rotation on the green node
next rr rotation
when a node is inserted into a right
subtree of the right subtree of a node
then we perform rr rotation
it is an anti-clockwise rotation which
is applied on the node below a node
having balance vector minus 2 that is we
will apply it on the green node
next up lr rotation
when a node is inserted into right
subtree of the left subtree of a node
then we perform lr's rotation
it is a combination of rr and ll
rotation
first we will apply rotation on green
and yellow node
after this red node is still unbalanced
so we will perform ll rotation on the
yellow node
finally
rl rotation
when a node is inserted into the left
sub tree of right subtree of a node then
we perform rl rotation
it is a combination of ll and rr
rotation
first we will apply ll rotation on green
and yellow nodes
after this the red node is still
unbalanced so we will perform ara
rotation on the yellow node
now let's discuss complexity of avl
trees
first up
space complexity is a bigger of n
next up avl tree offers a complexity of
bigger of log n for searching
next up
avl trees offer a complexity of bigger
of log n for insertion
finally
avl tree offers a complexity of bigger
of log n of for deletion
we have now introduced an avl tree and
rotations on it
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can perform on avl trees
first up insertion
and deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion we will insert a node
following binary search tree rules
then we will check if the nodes are
balanced or not if they are not then we
will balance it by using suitable
rotations
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
let's start by creating a node to create
a node we need a class node
we will create its member as public
and key
node star left
star
right
hint
height
now let's write a function to get
maximum of two integers
so
hint
max
a
comma
and b
now let's declare of utility function to
get maximum of two integers
so int
max
a
comma
end
v
now let's write a function to get the
height of the tree
and
height
node
star
n
now if
n is null
and we will return zero
else
we will return
and calls
now let's write that function to get
maximum of two integers
hint
max
and a
comma
and b
we will return
if
a is greater than b
then we will return a
else we will return b
now let's write a helper function that
allocates a new node with a given key
and null left and right pointers
so node
star
new node
and
key
star
node
goes to new
node
so node
key
will be equals to key
node
left
will be equals to
left
node
left
will be equals to null
and
node
right
will be equals to null
and node
height
will be equals to
1.
and
return
node
here we have kept height as one because
at the new node is initially added at
leaf so by default it will always be at
one
now let's write a utility function to
write rotate subtree rooted with y
node
star
right
not star y
now node
star x
is equals to
y is left
and
node
star
e2
is equals to
x
right
now we will perform rotation so
x right
will become y
and
y's left
will become t2
now we will update the heights so y
height
is equals to max
of
height
of y left
comma
hi
off
by
height
plus one
now
x
height
equals to
maximum of
height
hex
left
comma
height
of
x
right
plus one
now return
x
now let's write a utility function to
left rotate subtree rooted with x
node
left rotate
node star x
node
star y
will be equals to
access right
and
node
star t2
will be equals to xs
sorry
yes
now we will perform rotation so y
left
will be equals to x
and
x
right
will be equals to t2
now let's update height so x
height
is equals to
maximum of
height
of
excess left
comma
height
of
access right
and
why's height
equals to maximum of
height
of
y's left
comma
height
of
rise right
return
y
now let's write a function to get
balance vector of node n
so end
at
balance
argument as node pointer
and
if
n is n is equals to null
then we will return
0
otherwise
we will return
height
of
hence
left
minus
height of
hence right
now let's write a recursive function to
insert the key in the subtree rooted
with node and returns the new root of
the subtree
so
node
star
insert
nodes
star
node
comma hint
key
now we'll perform the normal bst
insertion so if
node is equals to null
then we will return
new
key
now if
this key
is
less than
node's key
then
node
left
will equals to
insert
node
left
comma key
or else
we will insert that in the right node
right
is equals to
insert
node
type
key
now we will return node
this if else will make sure that we will
reach to the leaf node and then we will
insert the key
now we will update the height of the
sensor node
so node
height
is equals to 1 plus
max
height
of code
left
comma
height
of node
right
now we will get the balance factor for
this ancestor
node to check whether this node became
unbalanced so int
balance
is equals to get
balance
now if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases
so if
balance
is greater than one
and
e
is less than
node
left
key
then
we will return
write
rotate
note
this if statement for the left left case
so or ll case
now let's write it for the right right
case or r case
so if
balance
is less than minus one
and
e
is greater than
node
right
key
then
we will return
left
rotate
node
now right for the left right case or lr
case
so if
balance
is greater than one
and
key
is greater than node
left
key
the node
left
is equals to
left
rotate
node
left
i'll return
right
rotate
now let's write the right left case or
rl case
so if
balance
is less than -1
and
key
is less than
node
to the right
key
and node
right
will be equals to
light
rotate
node
to the right
and we will return
left
rotate
now we will return this node
now let's write a function to print
pre-order traversal of this tree
so void
pre-order
node
star root
so now if
root
is not null
then
c out
root
key
and now pre
order
root
and pre-order
now let's write the code for the main
block
we will start with an empty tree
node
star root
is equals to null
now we will try to construct tree
root
is equals to
insert
root
comma 10.
our root
is equals to
insert
root comma
five
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
2
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
3
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
7
and root is equals to insert
now let's try to print this tree
so see out
here
tree
is equals to
order
spray order
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created our first avr tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following a binary
search tree rules
then we will check if all the nodes are
balanced or not if they are not then we
will balance it by using suitable
rotations
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
let's start by creating a node to create
a node we need a class
node
we will define its members as public
and key
note star
left
note star
right
and
height
now
let's write a utility function to get
height of the tree so end
height
node
star
n
f
n is equals to null
then in that case we will return
zero
otherwise we will return
hence height
now let's write a utility function to
get maximum of two integer
and
max
a comma and b
so we will return
if a is greater than b
then a
else
b
now let's write a helper function that
allocates a new node with a given key
and null left and right pointers
so node
star
u
node
and
key
so node
star
new node
is equals to new
node
parenthesis
now new node
will get
key as
key
new node
left
is equals to null
and new node
right
is equals to null
and new nodes
height
is equals to 1
because new node is initially added as
leaf
that's why it is always be given as 1.
now we will return this node return
node
now let's write a utility function to
write rotate a sub tree rooted with y
so node
are
write
rotate
node
star
y
star
x is equals to
y left
node
star t2
is equals to
x
right
now we will perform rotation so x
right
is equals to y
by
left
is equals to t2
now we will update heights
so y
high
equals to maximum of
height
of
y's left
comma
height
of
vice
right
plus one
and
x height
is equals to
maximum of
height
of
axis left
comma
access right
plus one
now we will return this new route so
return
x
now we will write
node
star
left
rotate node star
x
node star y
will be equals to access right
and
our star t2
will be equals to y's left
now we will perform rotation so y
left
equals to x
and x
right
is equals to t2
now we will update these heights so x
height
is equals to maximum of
height
of x
left
comma height
of
x
right
plus 1
and
wise height
is equals to
max
of height
of
twice left
comma height
of
wise
right
plus one
now we will return this y
now we will write a function to get
balance factor of node n
so int
cat
get balance
node star n
so if
n is equals to null
then we will return
zero
otherwise we will return
height
off
ends left
minus
height
of
ends right
now let's write a function to insert a
node
so node
star insert
so node
star
node
comma
end
key
now we will perform normal bst rotation
so if
node
is equals to null
and we will return
new node
key
so now if
key
is less than node key
then
node
left
will be equals to insert
node
is greater than node key
then
node
right
is equals to
insert
node
write
comma key
else
we will return
node
because
equal keys are not allowed
we will update the height of the
ancestral node
so node
height
equals to 1 plus
max
height
of node
left
comma height
of
node
right
now we will get the balance vector of
this ancestral node to check whether
this node becomes unbalanced
so if
end
balance
equals to
that
balance
of this node
now if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases that could be
possible
first up llks
so if
balance
is greater than
one
and
key
is less than
node left
return
write
rotate
mode
now let's write right right case
so if
balance
is less than -1
and
key is
greater than node
write
key
and we will return
left
rotate
node
now let's write left right case
so if
a lens
is greater than one
and
e
is greater than node
left
key
and
node
left
will be equals to
left rotate
node
and we will return
write
rotate
now let's write the case for right left
case
if
balance
is less than -1
and
e
is less than
node
right
so node
height
is equals to
write rotate
node
right
now we will return
left rotate
note
now let's return the unchanged node
pointer
so return
node
now let's write a function to find
minimum value node
so node
star
min
value
node
node star node
so node
star
current
equals to node
so while
current
left
is not equals to null
current
is equal to
current
at left
now we will return current
now we will write a recursive function
to delete a node with the given key from
subtree with the given root
so node
star
delete node
its arguments are
not pointer root
comma
end key
for starters we will perform standard
bst delete so if
root
is equals to null
then we will return
root
now if the key to be deleted is smaller
than the root key then it lies in the
left subtree
so
if
e
is less than
root
e
then
root
left
will be equals to
delete
node
root
to the left
comma key
now if key to deleted is greater than
the root key then it lies in the right
subtree
so else
if
e is greater than root
e
then
root
right equals to
delete
node
root
height
comma key
now if the key is same as the root key
then this is the node to be deleted so
else
if
root
the left
equals to
hull
power root
to the right
is equals to null
then node
star
temp
is equals to root
left
now if
temp
is equals to null
then temp
will be equal to root
and root
will equals to null
else
root
will be equals to star temp
and free
damp
it's
node
star temp
is equals to
min value node
root
right
now we will copy the inorder successors
data to this node so root
e
is equal to temp
key
now we will delete this in order
successor so root
right
is equals to
delete
mode
key
now if
root
is equals to null
then we will return
root
now we will update the height of the
current node
so root
height
is equals to 1 plus
max
of height
of roots left
comma
height
off
comma height
of root
height
now we will get the balance factor of
this node
so
end balance
is equals to
get
balance
root
if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases
first up ll case
so if
balance
is greater than one
and
that balance
of
roots
left
is greater than equals to
zero then we will return
right rotate
now if
balance
is greater than one
and
get
balance
of root
left
less than zero
then
root
left
will equals to left rotate
root
left
now we will return
right rotate
now let's write right right case so if
balance
less than minus 1
and
cat balance
is less than equals to zero
then we will return
left
rotate
now we will write right left case so if
balance
is less than -1
and
get balance
of root
right
is greater than zero
then
root
light
is equals to
right
rotate
right
now we will return
left rotate
and we will return this route
now let's write a function to print
pre-order traversal of this tree
so void
tree
order
code
star root
so if
root
not equals to
null
and c out
root
e
a pre-order
root
duct
and pre-order
root right
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with an empty tree so node
root
is equals to
null
now root
is equals to insert
root comma
two
root
is equals to insert
root comma
10.
root is equals to insert
root
comma
9
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
7
root is equals to insert
root comma five
root
is equals to insert
root comma three
now let's try and print this of avl tree
so see out
created
avl
pre-order
[Music]
now we will delete a node so root
is equals to
delete
node
root
comma
10.
now let's again try and print this
so see out
or defied
behavior
tree
pre-order
after
deletion
of
10.
layout
handle
pre order
root
now let's execute this
as you can see our deletion function is
working perfectly
now let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up avl trees is a self balancing
binary search tree
next every node must have a balance
factor of either -1 0 or 1.
next after every rotation we must verify
if each node is balanced or not
finally avl trees offers fast insertion
and deletion operations if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's get started with what is b3
b3 is a special amber tree data
structure
a b tree of order m can have at most m
minus 1 keys and m children
now let's discuss some properties of b
trees first up every node in a b tree
can have at most m elements
next every node except the root and the
leaf node must have m by two children
next a root node must have at least two
nodes
at last a leaf node must be at the same
level
now let's discuss what are the various
operations we can perform on a b tree
we can perform three operations on a b
tree that is searching
insertion
and deletion
let's discuss these in detail
first up searching in this we will
travel the complete b tree until we have
found a key
we will start from the left side to go
all the way up to the right side
now let's try this in a code editor
we will first start by creating a b tree
node
to do that we will use class
b tree node
and
keys
it is an array of keys
then end
t
this will define the range of the number
of
keys then we will
create a child pointer
e3
note
see
it is an array of child pointer
then
then a variable
to check the current number of keys
and a boolean variable
which will be true when the node is leaf
now define some
functions in public
first constructor
and a function to insert a new key in a
subtree
void
insert
non full
argument has been decay
next a utility function to split the
child y of the node
argument as end i
comma
a b tray note pointer
by
a function to traverse the b tree
and a function to search a key in the
sub tree
it will return null if key is not
present
now we will create another class b tree
and make it a friend of this so that we
can access private members of this b3
of this class in b tree function
now
we will create a pointer root
degree
then
public
a constructor b3
put equals to null
and t is equals to
score t
now we will write a function to traverse
this tree
point traverse
f
not
null
and root
traverse
now we will write a function to search a
key in this tree
return
if root is equals to
null
and null
else
root
now the main function that inserts the
new key in this b tree
void
insert
and okay
now
we will write the constructor for b tray
node class
now we will copy the given minimum
degree and leave property
now we will allocate the memory of the
maximum number of possible keys and the
child pointer
and c equals to
new
b3
node
star bracket
to start t
now we will initialize the number of
keys at zero
now let's write the function to traverse
all node in the subtree rooted with this
node
there are n keys and n plus one children
who traverse through n keys and first
and children's we need to do in eyes
for loop
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
if this is not leaf node then before
printing key
traverse the subtree rooted with child
cei
so if
if
equals to false
then
c bracket i
l equals to
traverse
else
c out
case
now we will print the subtree rooted
with the last node
so if
leaf
equals to false
and c
i
now we will write the function to search
key k in sub tray rooted with this node
so
b3
node
[Music]
search
we will first find the first key greater
than or equal to k
so
while
and i
is less than n
and
k
is greater than
is
bracket i
then i plus plus
now if we found the key is equals to k
then we will return this node
if
bracket i
is equals to k
then we will
return
if key is not found here and this is a
leaf node then
if
leaf is equals to
true
then we will return
now we will try to go to the appropriate
child
so we will use return
c bracket i
arrow
search
now we will write the bean function that
inserts the new key in this v tree
so void
b tree
insert
and k
so if
root
is equals to
null
then we will allocate the memory for
root
now root
keys
bracket 0
is equals to k
now we will change root
here we are updating the number of keys
in this route
now if else
else if tree is not empty
then
if root is full then tree grows in
height so
if
root
arrow n
is equals to
start t
minus one
then we will allocate the memory for the
new root
b3
star s
equals to new
a tree
node
t comma
false
now we will make the old root as child
of the new root
so
s arrow
c bracket zero
is equals to
root
now we will split the old root and move
one key to the new root
so
as
split child
now
new root has two childrens
we have to decide which of the two
children is going to have a new queue
new key
so in
i is equals to zero
if
if
as
keys
zero
is less than
okay
then
i plus plus
and s
arrow
c bracket i
arrow
insert
known
full
okay
now we will change the route
equals to s
else if root is not full we will call
the insert non-full
now we will write a function insert for
non-full
we'll initialize end
is equals to
n minus 1
f
if
is equals to
true
then
while
i is greater than equals to zero
and
if
is greater than k
then
case
i plus 1
will be equals to k is i
and i minus minus
now we will insert the new key at the
found location
else
while
i is greater than equals to zero
is
i
is greater than
okay
then
i minus minus
now we will see if the found child is
full
if
c
bracket
i plus 1
l
is equals to
2 star t
minus 1
then
we will use split child
i plus 1
comma
c
i plus one
now if
k is
bracket i plus 1
is less than k
then i plus plus
c
i plus one
insert
now we will write the function split
child
by
coma leaf
insert and
equals to
t minus one
now for do
and
j is equals to zero
j less than t minus one
j plus plus
z equals to
okay
equals to why
now we will copy the last t childrens of
y to z
if
y leaf
is equals to false
then four
into j
is equal to zero
j less than t
and j plus plus
now we will reduce repeat now we will
reduce the number of keys in y
since this node is going to have a new
child we will create a space for the new
child
so for loop
and
j is equals to 9
j goes to n
j
greater than equals to
i plus 1
j minus minus
c bracket
j plus 1
equals to
c bracket j
now we will link the new child to this
node
now a key of y will move to this node
and find the location of new key and
move all greater keys one space ahead
now we will increment the count of keys
in this node
now let's write the main block
we will define a b tree with menu of
degree 3.
now t dot insert
then
t dot insert
20
d dot insert
five
dot insert
six
t dot insert
12
a dot insert
30
d dot insert
seven
and
t dot insert
17.
now let's try to traverse this
see out
traversal
of
b3
t dot
now let's search some keys so let's take
end
k is equals to 6
so if
t dot search
okay
is not
null
then
see out
else
see out
not present
let's try this function one more time
with k is equals to
15
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
traversed this b tree and we have
checked two keys if they are present or
not the k is equals to
15 was not present and k is equal to 6
was present let's get back to our slides
next up insertion
we have to insert an element in such a
way so that we won't disobey any
properties of b trees now let's try this
operation in a code editor
we will start by creating a node to do
that we will use class
b3 node
then we will create an array of keys
minimum degree
an array of child pointers
current number of keys
and a boolean variable
leaf this variable will tell if the node
is leave or not
then we will define some public
functions
we will start with constructor
now we will create a function to insert
a new key
into the non-full node
a utility function to split the child
function to traversal
tree
a friend plus petery
now we will create this class b tree
now we will define a pointer to root
node
minimum degree
and we will create some public functions
first constructor
root equals to
null
and t equals to
underscore t
now
void
traverse
now if
root is not equational
and root
arrow
traverse
now we will define a main function that
inserts a new key in this bit tree
now we will write the constructor for
the b tree dot class
and t1
comma
boolean
leaf one
now we will copy the given minimum
degree and leave property
now we will allocate memory of maximum
number of possible keys and child
pointers
now we will initialize the number of
keys as zero
now let's write a function to traverse
all node in the sub tree
now there are n keys and n plus one
children so we will traverse through n
keys and first and center
so end
i
for loop
i is equal to zero
less than n
and i plus plus
now suppose if this is not leaf
then before printing key we will
traverse the subtree rooted with this
child so
if
if
is equals to false
then c i
arrow
traverse
now we will print these keys
now we will print the subtree rooted
with the last child
so if
leaf
is equals to
false
then
ci
arrow
traverse
now we will write the main function that
inserts a new key in this b tree
void
b3
now if tree is empty
and we will allocate the memory to root
so root
is equals to new
b3
node
e
comma
true
we will insert the key
root
arrow
keys
first okay
and we will update the number of keys in
root
root
arrow
and
equals to 1.
else
if tree is not empty
and if root is full then tree will grow
in height
if
root
arrow n
is equals to
2 star t minus 1.
now we will allocate the memory of new
roots
now we will make all root as child of
new root
is equals to
root
now we will split the old root and move
one key to the new root
so to do that we'll use split child
function
zero comma shoot
now new root has two children's now
we have to decide which of the two
children is going to have new key
so to do that we will use and i is
equals to zero
if
s keys
0 is less than k
then i plus plus
and s
arrow
c i
or non full
now we will change the
route else
root
insert
non-full
okay
now we will write a utility function to
insert a new key in this node
we will assume that node must be
non-full when this function is called
so void
b tree
node
insert
non-full we will initialize index as
index of right most element
so int
i is equals to n minus 1.
now if this is a leaf node
and the following loop does two things
a finds a location of new key to be
inserted or move all greater keys to one
place ahead
so
while
i is greater than equals to 0
and
is
i
is greater than k
now
is
i plus 1
will be equals to
keys
at i
and
i minus minus
now we will insert the new key at the
found location
so keys
at i plus 1
will be equals to k
and
n equals to n plus 1.
now else
if this node is not leave then we will
find the child which is going to have
the new key so while
i is greater than equals to 0
and
is
i
is greater than k
then
i plus i minus minus
now we will see if the found child is
full so if
c i plus 1
arrow n
is equals to
2 star t
minus one
now if the child is full then we will
split it
to
split
child
at i plus 1
comma
c
i plus 1.
after split the middle key of ci goes up
and ci is splitted into 2. now we will
see which of the following will have the
new key
f
keys
i plus 1
is
less than k
then i plus plus
c
i plus one
insert
normal
okay
child
and
i
comma
a3
node
now we will create a new node which is
going to store t minus keys of y
so b tree
node
star z
equals to
new
e3
node
y
arrow
d
comma
y arrow
leaf
now z
arrow n
is equals to t minus 1.
now we will copy the last d minus 1 case
of y to z
so for loop
j is equals to zero
a less than
t minus one
j plus plus
so z
arrow
is
j
equals to
y
arrow
is
j plus d
now we will copy the last t children of
y to z
so
f
y leaf is false
so for
and
j is goes to zero
j less than t
and j plus plus
so z
c j
is equals to
y
c
j plus t
now we will reduce the number of keys in
y
so y
arrow n
is equals to t minus 1
now since the node is going to have a
new child we will create the space for
the new child
so 4
into j
is equals to n
and j is greater than equals to i plus 1
and j minus minus
c
j plus 1
will be equals to
c j
now we will link the new child to this
node
so c bracket i plus 1
equals to z
now a key of y will move to this node
so we will find the location of new key
and move all greater keys one space
ahead
so for
int
j
is equals to
n minus 1
j greater than equals to i
j minus minus
is
a plus 1
2
is
j
now we will copy the middle key of y to
this node
so key is
bracket
i
is equals to
y
arrow
keys at t minus one
now we will increment the counts of key
in this node
so n equals to n plus 1
now we will write a driver program to
test above functions
now we will write the main block
we will start with a b tree with meaning
of degree 3.
now we will insert keys in this tree
t dot
insert
and
t dot insert
15
d dot
insert
five
d dot insert
x
d dot
insert
dot
insert
seven
now let's spread this constructor tray
so see out
created
b3
yes
now t dot
traverse
now let's execute this
as we can see we have created b3 of
order 3
let's get back to our slides
finally deletion
while deleting any elements from b3 we
have to be careful not to break any
properties of the b3 like all the leaves
must be present at the same level or
elements must be in ascending order
now let's try this operation in a code
editor
let's start by creating a node to create
a node we need a class
node
end
start keys
this is an array of keys
entity
a minimum degree
now we will define an array of child
pointers
so b3 node
number of keys and
a boolean variable leave to tell us if
the node is leaf or not
now we will define some public functions
we will start with the constructor to
this class
b3
node
and underscore t
comma
boolean
underscore leaf
and a function to traverse the all nodes
in the subrooted tree
so void
traverse
now a function to search a key in the
subtree
so b3
node star
search
and okay
this will returns null if k is not
present
now we will write a function that
returns the index of the first key that
is greater or equal to k
so end
key
and k
now we will write an utility function to
insert a new key in this subtree
rooted with this node
we will be assuming the node must be
non-full when this function is called
so void
insert
non-full
as argument as
k
now we will write a utility function to
split the child of y
of this node
void
let
child
and
i
comma
b3
node
star
y
a wrapper function is to remove the keys
k in substituted with this node
so void
remove
end key
another function to remove a key present
in the eighth height position in this
node which is a known leaf node so void
remove
from non-leaf
and
idx
now we will write a function to get the
predecessor of the key where the key is
present in the idx
portion in the node
so end
get
ready
and idx
now we will write a function to get the
successor of the key where the key is
present in the idx position in the node
so end
get
successor
and
idx
now we will write a function to fill up
the child node present in the idx
position
in the c array if that child has less
than t minus 1 keys
subvoid
fill
and
idx
now we will write another function to
borrow a key
from the c idx minus one node and place
it and place it in c idx node
so void
borrow
a function to borrow a key from the idx
plus one node and place it at the i
idx node
so void
borrow
from
next
and
idx
void
merge
idx
now we will make b3 class
as friend so that we can access private
members of the this class in the b3
functions
so friend
class
b3
so class
we'll start with the pointer to the root
node
so b3
node
star root
t
now we will write some public functions
we will start with the constructor so b3
and
underscore t
so
root is equals to
null
and t is equals to
underscore t
now
a traverse function
void
traverse
so we will check if
root is not null
then
root
arrow
traverse
now we will write a function to search a
key in this tree
so b3
node
search
and key
we will return
if
root is equals to
null
then we will return null
else
root
arrow
search at key
now we will write the main function that
inserts a new key in this b tree
so void
insert
int
k
now another main function that removes
the new key in this b tree
so void
removed
now we will write the constructor for
this big tree node
and d1 comma
bull
leaf
one
so t will be equals to t1
and
leaf
will be equal to leaf one
now we will allocate memory for the
maximum number of possible keys and
child pointers
so keys
is equals to
new
hint
minus one
and child c is equals to new
b3 node
star bracket
2 star t
now we will initialize the number of
keys as 0 so n is equals to zero
now we will write a utility function
that returns the index of the first e
that is greater than or equal to k
so
end
b3
node
find
key
int
k
now end
by dx
is equals to zero
then while
i dx
is less than n
and
keys
idx
is less than k
plus plus
idx
return
idx
now we will write a function to remove
the key k from the subrout tray rooted
with this node so world
v3
node
remove
and k
and
idx equals to
point key
okay
if the key to be removed is present in
this node then
if
idx
is less than n
and
keys
at idx
is equals to k
now if node is leaf node
then we will remove from leaf node is
called
otherwise remove from non leaf function
is called
so if
leave
then remove
from
leaf
idx
else
remove
from
only
idx
now else
if this node is a leaf node then the key
is not present in the stream
so
if
leave
see out
hey
is
does not
exist
industry
and return
the key to be removed is present in this
subtree rooted with this node the flag
indicates whether the key is present in
this subtree rooted with the last child
of this node
so
bull
black
is equals
to idx
equals to n
if
it is true
else false
if the child where the key is supposed
to exist has less than t keys then we
fill that child
so if
c
at idx
and
is less than t
then fill
idx
now if
flag and
i dx
is greater than n
and c
dx
minus one
remove
okay
else
c
idx
remove
okay
return
void
b tree
node
remove
from leaf
and
idx
now we will move all the keys after the
idx position one place backward
so
for loop
and
i is equals to i dx plus one
idx plus one
i less than n
i plus plus
plus plus i
so keys
at i minus 1
should be equal to
i
and we will reduce the count of keys so
n
minus minus
and return
now we will write the function to remove
the idx key from the node which is
non-leaf node
so void
d3
node
remove
from non-leaf
and
idx
so int
k is equals to
keys
at idx
if the child that precedes k at c i d x
has at least t keys
then we will find the predecessor thread
of k in the sub tree rooted at c i d x
we will replace k by predecessor
recursively and delete thread in c i d x
so if
c i d x
arrow
and
is greater than equals to
t
then end
equals to
get red
idx
keys
idx
equals to
red
c
idx
remove
that
else
if
c at i d x plus one
arrow
and
is greater than equals to
d
and end
suck
is equals to
get
suck
idx
up keys at idx
is equals to suck
c at idx 1
you just remove
suck
else
will merge
idx
and see
at idx
we'll call
remove
at idx will call
remove
return
now we will write a function to get
predecessor of keys idx
so int
b3
node
get red
and
suck
repeat
and idx
so b3
node
star curve
is equal to c at idx
while
is not a leaf
calls and
now we will return
key
now we will write
end
bakery
node
that
suck
and
idx
goes to c
i d x
plus one
while
curve
arrow
while curve is not leaf
or
now we will return
now we will write a function to fill
child c idx which has less than t minus
1 keys
void
b3
node
and
idx
f
repeat if the previous child c idx minus
1 has more than t minus 1 keys then we
will borrow a key from that child
so if i dx
is not equals to 0
and
c at i i dx
minus 1
calls
n
greater than equals to
t
then we will borrow from prev
idx
else
if
i dx is not equals to n
and
c at i dx
plus one
calls
n
greater than equals to 1
30
then
we will borrow
from next
at idx
else
if
i dx
is not equals to n
and we will merge
idx
yes
merge
idx
minus 1
return
now we will write a function borrow from
prevent
a tree node
star child
is equal to c idx
a train
node
star sibling
is equals to c
idx
minus one
now
the last key from c i dx minus 1 goes up
to the parent and key idx minus 1 from
parent is inserted as the first key in c
i d x thus the losses sibling one key
and child gains one key
moving all keys in c i d x one step
ahead so for loop
and
i
is equals to
child
at n
minus 1
i greater than equals to 0
and i minus minus
minus minus i
child
calls keys
at i plus 1
equals to
child
calls
keys
at it
now if cidx is not a leaf
then we'll move all its child pointers
one step ahead
if underscore
child calls leave
or
and
i
equals to
child
and
i
greater than
equals to zero
i
minus minus i
child
at c bracket i plus one
equals to
child
c bracket i
so
now we will set the child's first key
equal to the key at idx minus 1 from the
current node
so child
is
at zero
is equals to
keys that idx minus one
now we will move siblings last child as
ci dx's first set
so if
child is not leave
and child
arrow
c bracket 0
is equals to
sibling
at
c
sibling
because
now
keys
at idx minus 1
will be equals to sibling
case
sibling false
n minus 1
now child
at n
will be plus equals to
one
and sibling
and
will be equals to minus equals to
1
return
void
b3
node
arrow
from next
int idx
now we will start by b3
node child
is equal to c at idx
and b3
node
sibling
is equals to c at i d x
plus one
now key idx is inserted as the last key
in the cidx
so child
keys
um
is equal to
keys
at
now
idx
at keys
next
if
child is not live
let's see
equals to
sibling
at
c
zero
now
the first key from sibling is inserted
into key idx
so key at idx
is equals to
sibling
keys
zero
for loop
and
i is equals to one
i
less than
sibling
at hand
plus high
sibling
i
minus 1
is equals to
sibling
now if
sibling is not leave
follow
i equals to one
less than equals to
sibling calls n
plus plus i
false
c
at i minus 1
equals to
sibling
calls c at i
now we will be increasing and decreasing
the key count of c i d x and c i d x
plus 1 respectively
so
child
at n
is plus equals to
1
sibling
calls
n
minus equals to
one
return
now void
b3
node
merge
with argument as and idx
b3
node
star child
is equal to c dx
b tree
node
or sibling
let's do c
at idx plus one
now we will be pulling a key from the
keyed node and inserting it at t minus
one position is c i d x
so
child
calls keys
t minus 1
is equals to
case
at idx
now we will be copying
keys from cidx 1 to cidx at the end
so for
end i
is equals to zero
i less than sibling
plus n
and plus plus i
so
child i plus d
equals to
sibling
if
our child
calls
leave
for
i is equals to 0
i
less than equals to
sibling
calls
plus i
child
now four
and
is equals to idx
plus one
i less than n
plus plus i
i minus 1.
is equals to
keys
at it
or
and
i is equals to
i dx plus 2
i less than equals to
n
and plus plus i
e
at i minus 1
is equals to
c
at i
child
and
plus
equals to
sibling
and
plus one
delete
disabling
return
now we will write the mean function that
inserts a new key in this b tree
so void
b tree
and k
if
root is equals to
null
then we will allocate
memory to root
sequence to
new
b3 node
d
comma true
[Music]
root
is
bracket zero
is equals to k
and root
at n
is equals to one
else
if
root
calls
is equals to
2 star
t minus 1.
so b3
node
star s
is equals to
new
b3
node
e
comma false
now s
c bracket zero
equals to
root
as
split
side
zero comma
root
and
i is equals to zero
f
s
keys
bracket 0
less than k
[Music]
i plus plus
s
c bracket hi
now we will change the route to s
else
root
calls
insert
non-full
add key
a utility function to insert at non-full
node
end
i
is equals to n minus 1
f leaf equals to true
the following loop does two things
finds the location of key to be inserted
or moves all greater key to one place
ahead
so while
i
is greater than equals to zero
and
keys
at i
are greater than k
then
keys
at i plus 1
will be equals to
keys at i
and i
minus minus
keys
at i plus 1
will be equals to
a
and n will be equals to n plus 1
else
while
i is greater than equals to zero
and
is
at
greater than k
i minus minus
f
c bracket i plus 1
at n
equals to
2 star
t minus 1
child
i plus one
comma
c
i plus one
f
is
bracket i plus one
okay
i plus plus
c bracket
i plus one
insert non-poll
okay
world
b3
node
i
comma
b3
node
star y
b3
node
star z
is equal to new
b3
node
argument as y calls t
and y calls leaf
now that calls
n equals to
t minus 1
now we will copy the last t minus 1 keys
of y to z
so for loop
and j is equals to 0
j less than
e minus 1
j plus plus
so z keys
okay
is equals to
y
at keys
j plus
t
so if
y
if
equals to
false
for
and
j is equals to zero
j
less than t
j plus plus
j
c bracket i
is equals to
y calls
c bracket j plus
e
now y calls
n equals to t minus 1
now since this node is going to have a
new child we will create space for the
new child
so for loop
and
j is equals to n
j greater than equals to
i plus 1
j minus minus
c vector
j plus 1
equals to c bracket
j
now c bracket
i plus 1
is
equals to
c bracket
j
e bracket
i plus 1
is equals to z
now for loop
and
j is equals to n
minus 1
j greater than equals to
i
j
minus minus
is bracket j
plus 1
equals
to keys
at j
is i
equals to
y
is
bracket
t minus one
n is equals to n plus one
now we will write function for traverse
so void
b tree node
traverse
i
for loop
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
if
leave
equals to false
and c bracket i
will traverse
if
if
is equals to false
and see i
will call
traverse function
now we will write the function to search
key in the subtree rooted with this node
so b3
node
star
betrayal
node
search
and
okay
and
i is equals to 0
while
i is less than n
ampersand
k
is greater than keys
bracket i
plus plus
now if
is bracket i
is equals to k
and return
is
now if
if
is equals to true
then return
null
otherwise return
c bracket i
calls
search
okay
now we will write the utility function
to remove
so void
e3
remove
hint
okay
f
not root
and c out
the
tree
is empty
return
now we will call the reboot repeat now
we will call the remove function for
root
so root
calls
remove
okay
now if root has zero keys then we will
make its first child as a new root
if it has a child
otherwise set root as
null so if
root
n
is equals to zero
then b3
node
star
tmp
equals to root
if
root
leaf
root equals to
null
else
root
equals to
root
c bracket
zero
now delete
return
now we will write the code for the main
block
we will start with b3
of order 3.
now let's traverse this crater tree
see out
created
tree
now see out
and l
now we will use t dot remove
to remove five
now see out
modified
p3
after
deleting
five
dot traverse
as you can see we have successfully
deleted five from our b tree
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up all the operations on b3 have
time complexities of log n
next all the leaves must be on the same
level
next elements of b3 are sorted in
ascending order from left to right
finally every node contains one more
pointer than the number of elements of
the node let's get started with what is
a b plus tree
a b plus tree is a special m by tree
data picture a b plus tree of order m
can have at most m minus one keys and m
children
a b plus tree can be used as b tree with
only keys to each node and with linked
leaves to which an additional level is
added at the bottom
now let's discuss some properties of b
plus trees
first up every node in b 3 can have at
most m elements
next every node except the root and the
leaf node must have m by 2 children
next
maximum keys for any node is m minus 1
and at the last minimum keys for any
node is ceiling of m by 2 minus one
now let's discuss what are the various
operations we can perform on b plus
three
we can perform two operations on a b
plus tree
first up insertion
second deletion
now let's discuss these in detail
first up insertion
we have to insert an element is in such
a way so that we won't disobey any
properties of b plus trees
now let's try this operation in a code
editor
we will start by creating a node to
create a node we need a struct
b plus
tree
node
in
star data
b plus
tree node
space star
child btr
boolean
leaf
and end and
for the object star root will be equals
to null
star
and p pointer
will be equals to null
comma
star x will be equals to null
now we will write a constructor for it
so b
node
star highlight
and
i
and p equals to
mu
b plus
tree node
np arrow
data
is equals to new
space and
bracket 5.
nnp
child
ptr
is equals to new
b plus 3
node
star
bracket
sex
and belief
is equals to
true
and then p at the
n
is equals to zero
now we will write a for loop
i is equals to zero
i less than six
i plus plus
np child
is equals to
return
traverse
b plus
3
node
and
i
again afford to
from i equals 0
to
i less than p at n
i plus plus
f
p doesn't have leave
then we will traverse that child
traverse
child
ptr bracket high
see you
p data
at i
now we will check these conditions again
for
i at t at n
we will traverse it again
from p
child
handle
now next function will be used to sort
this
so void
sort
and start the
comma
and
for loop
a equals to i
a less than equals to n
j plus
f
p bracket i
greater than p bracket j
then
we will swap these two
so temp
will store p at i
and then p will replace its value with p
at j
now we will store
the temp value in the p of j
now let's write a function to split this
side
and
set
child
e plus 3
node
star x
comma
and i
b plus
3 node
star np1
comma
star
np3
comma star y
and b3
is equals to
finite
and p3
equals to true
f
i
is equals to minus one
mid
is equals to
x
data
bracket
2. x data
bracket 2
will be equals to 0
then
x
will store n minus minus
p1
is to finite
now when p1 leave
will be equals to false
and x leaf is equal to true
for loop
j is equals to
three j less than 5
j plus
a minus 3
will be equals to
x
data
j
23
child
peter
at j minus 3
is equals to
x at child ptr
bracket j
np3
and plus plus
x
data bracket j
is equal to zero
now x
greater than
n minus minus
another for loop
from j is equals to zero
with j less than six
j plus plus rate
x
child ptr
a j
will be stored at null
now
np1
data
at zero position
will be equals to mid
and p1
child ptr
at
and p1
on
will be equals to x
and p1
child
at np1
on n plus 1
will be equals to np3
p1
call n plus plus
root
is equals to
np1
now else
y is equals to
x
child
ptr at i
and mid is equals to y at data
at two
and y
on data at 2.
is equals to zero
i will store n minus minus
now for loop
j is equals to three
j lesson 5
j plus plus
np3
data
j minus 3
is equal to
y
data
a
and p3
and plus
y
data
bracket j
is equal to zero
why
and minus minus
x
child
ptr at i plus 1
is equals to y
x
at
child ptr
i plus 1
is equals to
np3
return
now we will write a function to insert
into the tree
avoid
insert
argument as a
so end
i
comma temp
x is equal to root
if
x equals to null
then root
is equals to
finite
and x will be equals to root
otherwise
if
x is a leaf
and
x at nine eight and exit n
is equals to five
and temp
is equal to
split
child
x
comma minus 1
x is equal to root
f
a is greater than
x
at i
and
a is less than
x
at data
i plus one
i plus plus
and break
else
if
a is less than
x
data
zero
then break
else
continue
x is equals to x at
child
at i
else
hex leaf
is false
for loop
i is equal to zero
when
i is less than x at n
i plus plus
if
a is greater than
x
at tata
i
and
a is less than
x
and data
i plus one
a plus plus
break
else
if
a is less than x
data
break
else
continue
if
x
child
at n
is equals to five
that temp
is equals to split
child
at x comma i
x
data
at x and on n
is equals to temp
x
at n plus plus
continue
else
x is equals to x
child
right here
i
x
on data
at
x at n
is equals to a
sort
hex at data
exit n
x at n plus
now let's write the code for the main
block
first we will declare some variables
as and i n
and t
now we will request
enter
number
of
element
to be
inserted
in
pattern
now see out
now we will enter the element so enter
the
element
now we will write a for loop
i is equals to 0
to i less than n at i plus plus
so cn
d
and insert
d
now we will traverse this
tree so see out
traverse
cell
of
b plus 3
traverse
route
let's execute this
we will enter 5 elements
2 comma 3 comma 5 comma 7 comma 9
as you can see we have successfully
traversed our first b plus tree
let's get back to our slides
next deletion while deleting any element
from b plus 3 we have to be careful not
to break any properties of b plus tree
like all the leaves must be present at
the same level or elements must be in
ascending order
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
let's start by creating a b plus tree
first we will declare a global variable
and
max equals to 3
then we
will a class
pp tree
and a class
node
boolean
is leaf
and
start key
comma size
code
star ptr
and a friend class
now public
load
variable
now we will write
plus
pptree
so node
star root
void
insert
kernel
and
node star
comma
node
star
void
remove internal
paint comma
node
star
comma
node star
and a node function
find
parent
now public
pptree
the constructor
a search function
insert function
void remove
void
display
get root
is equal to new
and
bracket max
is equals
to new
node
star
bracket max plus one
tree
let's do another
now void
with
lipy tray
insert
and
x
if
true
is equals to null
then root
is equal to
new
node
root
calls key
at 0
0
root
checks
its leaf
ice
is equals to 1.
else
node
cursor
is equals to root
node
star
parent
wife
cursor
is
leave
is equals to
false
cursor
now for loop
and i is equals to 0
to i less than
cursor
size
i plus plus
f
x is less than cursor
key
at i
cursor
is equals to cursor
at
ptr
at i
if
i
is equals to
cursor
size
-1
cursor
break
now if
person
size
is less than max
then end
i is equals to 0
while
x is greater than cursor
e
hit i
and
i is less than
cursor
size
for loop
and
is equals to
cursor
at size
and j
is greater than i
a minus minus
so cursor
calls key
at j
is equals to
cursor
pulse key
at j minus 1.
cursor
calls key
at i
is equals to x
cursor
calls size
plus plus
cursor
calls
ptr
add cursor
size
is equals to
cursor
ptr
at
cursor size
-1
now cursor
at ptr
cursor
size
minus one
cursor
ptr
equals
else
node
equals to new
virtual
node
max plus one
for
and
i is equals to 0
to i less than max
at the rate i plus plus
so virtual node
at i
is equals to
cursor
hair dye
while
x is greater than
virtual
node
mercury
i is less than max
i plus plus
for
int
j is equals to max
plus one
comma j is greater than
i
g minus minus
virtual
node
let's say
is equals to
virtual
load
at j minus one
so virtual
node
i
is equals to x
so new leaf
is leave
is equals to true
cursor size
is equals to
max
plus 1
by 2.
new leaf
size
is equals to max
plus one
minus
max
plus
one divided by 2
pressure
nice
is equals to
new leaf
new leaf
new leaf
is equal to
cursor
ptr
max
now void
bp tree
insert
internal
cursor
comma
node
star
child
f
cursor size
is less than max
then
end is equals to zero
while
x is greater than
cursor
at
key
at i
and
i is less than
cursor
of size
i plus plus
for loop
and
j is equals to
cursor size
a is greater than
i
j minus minus
cursor
at key
at j
is equals to cursor
a minus one
cursor
key
cricket eye
is equals to x
cursor
size
plus plus
cursor
at ptr
bracket i plus one
as equals to child
else
node
star
internal
is equals to
new node
and
virtual
key
is max plus one
node
star
virtual
key
at maths
plus one
virtual
ptr
at
is equal to zero
i less than
max i plus plus
virtual
key
i
is equals to
cursor
key
four
i less than max
plus one
virtual
ddr
i
first of cursor
ptr
at eye
node
star
pp tree
find
parent
node
star
cursor
comma
node
star child
load
start parent
if
cursor
is leave
or
cursor
at
atr
zero
yes
then return
none
for
loop
and
i is equal to 0
i less than
cursor
size
plus one
i plus plus
f
cursor
child
return
parent
else
parent
is equals to find
parent
cursor
dtr
right
if
parent
not equals to
null
return
now void
repeat tray
remove
and x
if
out
empty
else
node
star cursor
goes to
root
or
star parent
and
left
sibling
comma
right
sibling
so while
cursor
s
leaf
equals to
false
so for
i is equals to zero
i less than cursor size
and i plus plus
parent is equals to cursor
left
sibling
is equals to i minus one
right
sibling
is equals to i plus 1
if
x is less than
i
then cursor
will be equals to cursor
ptr
now if
i is equal to
cursor
size
minus one
to y plus 2
cursor
is equals to
cursor
bracket i plus one
click
is equals to
false
zero
force is less than
cursor
size
force
plus plus
f
pressure
key
advance
is equals to
x
then found
equals to true
and then break
now if
not found
not
done
now if
cursor
size
equals to zero
then
see out
right
delete
cursor
late
delete
cursor
root
is equals to
null
return
for loop
and
i is equals to
cursor
zero
j
less than
right node
size
i plus plus
comma j plus plus
cursor
key
at i
is equals to
right node
pressure
and cursor
size
first one
now see out
merging
remove
internal
right sibling
minus one comma
parent
comma
right node
delete
write
node
key
write node
right now
avoid
e3
display
if
cursor
is not equals to null
for
i equals to one
i less than
cursor
size
i plus
see out
key
see out
handle
if
cursor
is
leave
not equals to true
and for
and
i equals to zero
i less than cursor
size
plus one
i plus plus
pressure
ptr
node
star bp3
get root
return
root
now we will write the main block
will start with an empty tree vp tree
node
now node
dot
insert
5
node
dot insert
15
node
dot insert
25
node dot insert
35
dot insert
dot
display
dot
get
true
node
dot remove
15
dot display
dot
root
let's execute this
as you can see
this program is working flawlessly we
have successfully deleted the key 15.
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first of b plus trees are fast at
performing all its operations
next all the leaves must be present on
the same level and data is only stored
in leaf node
next elements of the b plus tree are
sorted in ascending order from the left
to the right
finally every node contains one more
pointer than the number of elements of
the node
let's try to understand what is a bubble
sort algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm is one of the
fundamental and simplest forms of
algorithm used to sort a collection of
elements the collection of elements can
be either a set of numbers or characters
the control iterates through a sequence
of numeric or character type elements in
the bubble sort algorithm and rearranges
them into ascending or descending order
the bubble sort algorithm rearranges one
element at a time
the bubble sort algorithm is also known
as the sinking algorithm
here we have some random distributed
elements which are 30
10
20
50 and 40 and after performing the
bubble sort algorithm all the elements
are sorted as 10
20 40 and 50.
so how is it done
we will see in the next segment where we
will understand the working
terminologies of bubble sort algorithm
the bubbles sort algorithm will not get
implemented on the entire array in one
go instead it compares two adjacent
pairs of elements in an array if the
elements are not in the correct order
then they are swapped so the largest of
the two moves towards the right and this
process continues until the most
significant element or bubble is moved
towards the highest position
after the first process is finished the
search for the next most significant
object starts and the swapping continues
until the whole array is in correct
order this process is employed when you
want to arrange the elements in
ascending order
to understand the logic in a better way
let's go through an example
the example on my screen consists of
five elements according to the bubble
sort algorithm logic we need four
iterations to sort all the elements in
the ascending order or in descending
order the elements in the array are as
follows they are 3 8 4 2 and 12. so in
this array the index begins with 0 and
ends with 4
and each time the bubble sort algorithm
goes through the data element list and
it is known as a pass
let us analyze the total number of
comparisons required to sort the array
in the correct order
according to the formula
if n is the total number of elements in
an array then the total number of
comparisons needed to sort the entire
array can be calculated by a simple
formula shown on my screen that is n
is equals to n minus 1
so in this scenario we need 5 minus 1
that is 4 comparisons or passes to sort
the entire array in the first pass there
are 4 steps
let us select the first two elements
that is 3 and 8 according to the
requirement we need to sort this array
in the ascending order hence when we
compare 3 and 8 clearly we get 3 as the
least number so we do not need to swap
them
next is the step 2 comparing the second
and third elements which are 8 and 4
here we need to swap these two elements
because
eight is always greater than four and it
requires placing the elements in the
ascending order
now moving ahead we have step three
moving on to the third and fourth
elements which are eight and two and
here again we need to swap eight with
two because eight is greater than two
and in the step four
we have we have the last elements which
are eight and twelve there is no need to
swap because eight is already less than
twelve so you can see it clearly so now
we enter into past two and in past two
we need three steps
so the first step in the second pass let
us select the first two elements which
are three and four
no swapping is necessary as they are
already in order
next we have step two
in step two we need to select the
elements two and four as you can see two
is always less than four so there is no
swapping required
next we have step 3 in step 3 we need to
compare the elements 4 and 8 and here we
may not need any switching because 4 is
already less than 8. now here you can
see that we are not comparing 8 and 12
because the last element is already
sorted
now we have come to the last pass
and here there is only one step the step
is to compare the first two elements 2
and 3 and then swap them as 3 is greater
than 2. now the array is finally sorted
and we do not need to do any more
comparisons
after understanding the working process
of the bubble sort algorithm we will see
its pseudo code in this pseudo code
there is a function named as bubble sort
the bubble sort function includes an
array of collections of sortable
elements let us consider n as the length
of the array after that we have to
repeat comparisons for the first element
to the last element of the array if the
first element is greater than its next
consecutive element then we must swap
both the elements and place them
correctly we do not need to switch after
closing this repeated statement and
getting out of the loop
this bubble sort function will end after
understanding the pseudo code of the
bubble sort algorithm let's learn about
the optimized bubble sort algorithm so
we can optimize the algorithms in a loop
by programming it to avoid the
comparison at n minus 1 position after
every iteration since the nth element is
already sorted in the previous iteration
more generally
more than one element may be placed in
their final position on a single pass
all the elements after the last swap are
sorted in every pass and do not need to
be rechecked optimized bubble sort
algorithm allows skipping over many
elements this results in a worst case
that is 50 percent improvement in
comparison count and adds little
complexity because of the new code sub
sums the swapped variable
next we will learn variations of the
bubble sort algorithm so there are two
variations of the bubble sort algorithm
they are
odd even sort and cocktail shaker
so odd even sort is a parallel version
of bubble sword for the message passing
system
whereas cocktail shaker is a sort of
bi-directional bubble sort that first
goes from beginning to the end and ends
to the beginning after knowing the
variation of the bubble sort algorithm
now we will see the complexity of bubble
sort algorithm
so the best case of the bubble sort
algorithm is big o of n where n is the
number of elements being sorted and
worst and average cases of the bubble
set algorithm are big o of n into n and
lastly the space complexity of the
bubble sort algorithm is big of one
here n is the number of data elements
being sorted let us understand when this
complexity occurs the best case of
bubble sort algorithm is o of n which
occurs at all the data elements in an
array are already sorted here we have an
example with some data elements in an
array which are already sorted that is
10 20 30 40 and 50.
next talking about the average and worst
case the worst case and average case of
the bubble set algorithm is o of n to
the power 2 that is n squared or n into
n it occurs when all the data elements
in an array are reversely sorted again
we have an example that consists of data
elements that are reversely sorted that
are 50 40 30 20 and 10 in an array
lastly we have space complexity the
space complexity of bubble sort
algorithm is o of one because only one
additional variable is required to
implement bubble sort algorithm that is
temporary variable we came to the last
topic where we will understand four main
applications of bubble sort algorithm
first application of bubble sort
algorithm states that this sorting
technique is used to sort the elements
in a specific order the bubble sort
algorithm uses less storage and is the
second application of bubble sort
algorithm third the real life
application states that the bubble sort
algorithm is used to store the students
based on their height in a line
lastly bubble sort is used to create a
stack pile up the elements based on
their height after covering all the
bubble sort algorithm topics we will now
see a practical demonstration of bubble
sort algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
bubble sort algorithm so let us get
started with the code in this code at
the first position we have some header
files that is standard input output
standard library etc after that we will
define the main function in the main
function we will declare an array with
maximum size of 50. so here you can see
that we have the first array variable
that size is 50. size will be defined
with declaration only because we cannot
change the array size in the run time
after that we will declare four
variables that is a
b
num and temp
non variable will store the number of
elements of an array after that we will
ask the user how many elements are
required for the array using printf
function
so here is the printf function where we
will be asking the
user to enter the number of elements in
an array and the user will enter the
elements and this will be done using
scanf function then finally we will
print all the elements that the user
wants to store in an array using another
printf function
we will have three loops firstly there
will be a loop from the first element to
the last element of the array so this is
the first for loop we need then second
the for loop will use the variable a for
the rotation purpose as we know rotation
equal to number of elements minus 1 so
it will make a loop from index 0 to
number -1
the last loop is used for how many
passes will be required for the
implementation and we already pass
equally to the number of elements minus
number of rotations minus 1. so there is
the loop from index 0 to number minus a
minus 1 then there will be the if
condition stating that if the first
element of an array at index b is
greater than the element at the index b
plus 1 then we will make swap then we
will come out of the loop and we will
print all the array elements after
performing the bubble sort algorithm now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed now let us enter
the number of elements let me choose
five
now let us enter the elements in a
random
order so this was the array input 3 2 4
1 and 5 and here after executing the
bubble sort algorithm we have the sorted
array that is 1 2 3 4 and 5. let's get
started with an introduction to
insertion sort
insertion sort is basically a sorting
algorithm in which each item in the
final sorted array is sorted one at a
time
and it is significantly less sufficient
than more sophisticated algorithms like
quick sort heap sort or merge sort on
larger data sets
now let's discuss the algorithm of
insertion sort
let's say we have an array we will start
with traversing the array from index 1
to n minus 1.
while traversing we will compare
elements at the current index to its
predecessor
if the data at the current index is
smaller than its predecessor then we
will compare it with the element before
that
after that we will shift bigger elements
to an index up to make space for swapped
elements
then we will shift the bigger elements
to an index up to make space for the
swapped element and then we will iterate
the same steps again to sort the
complete array
we have now introduced the insertion
sort and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start with creating a function
to sort an array using insertion sort so
void insertion sort
we will give it argument as end array
arr
comma int
size
we will declare variables and i
comma key
comma j
now
we will create a loop for loop
from i is equals to
1
to i less than size
i plus plus
here we are traversing this array from
index one to the size n minus one
so key
is equals to
arr
at i
and j is equals to
i minus 1
now we will move the elements of arr 0
to i minus 1
that are greater than the key to one
position ahead of the current position
so while
j
is greater than equals to
zero
and
arr at j
is greater than key
and we will swap these
so a ir
at j plus 1
is equals to a r r
f j
and j will be equals to j minus 1.
and then we will assign arr j plus 1
is equals to key
now we will write a function to print
this array
of size
void
and
array
we will give its argument as end
array
and
size size
we will declare int i is equals to zero
for loop
i is equal to zero
i
less than size
i plus plus
c out
arr
arr
bracket ie
and say out
handle
now we will write the main block
so end
arr
is equals to
12 comma
11 comma 15 comma
9 comma six comma seven
and
size is equals to we will find the size
using size of
so size is equals to size of
arr
divided by size of
arr at index 0.
now we will print this array without
sorting
so c out
unsorted array
we will print
array
error comma size
now we will call insertion sort
ar comma size
c out
we will print this
array
sorted
now we will again call print
array
argument as arr comma
size
now let's print this
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly it has sorted this array
let's get started with an introduction
to selection sort
the selection sort algorithm is an
in-place comparison based method that
divides the list into two halves with
the sorted portion on the left and the
unsorted half on the right
then the smallest element from the
unsorted array is chosen and swept with
the leftmost element and that element is
added to the sorted error
now let's discuss the selection sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array first we will
divide this array in two sub-arrays
unsorted array and sorted array
then we will divide the minimum element
from the unsorted array and swap it with
the leftmost element of this unsorted
array after that we will add it to the
unsorted array
we will keep repeating this process
until there are no elements left on the
unsorted array
we have now introduced
selection sort and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
argument will be integer pointer
x
comma
integer pointer
y
we will declare an element temp
to store the value of
pointer x
then we will store pointer wise value in
x
and we will store temps value in wire
and that's how we can swap them
next we will write the definition of
selection sort function
void
selection sort
argument will be end
array arr
comma
and
n
we will declare variables and i
j
and a min underscore idx
variable to store the minimum index
now we will one by one move boundaries
of unsorted sub arrays so for loop
i is equals to 0
where i is less than n minus 1
i plus plus
we will find the minimum element in this
unsorted array so
min
underscore
idx
is equals to i
now for
a is equals to
i plus 1
j less than n
j plus plus
if
array element at j location
is less than
array at the min index
then
min idx
will be updated with j
now we will swap the form minimum
element with the first element
so
we will call swap function
with argument as
ampersand
arr
at min idx
comma
ampersand
arr
at ith location
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
array
argument as int arr
and its size
and
n for loop
and
i is equals to 0
i less than
n
i plus plus
t out
arr
at i
layout
and l
now we will write the code for the main
block
so end
arr
is equals to
4 comma 2 comma 1 comma 8 comma 3.
we will find the size of this array so
end n is equals to
size of
array arr
divided by
size of
this arrays first element
now we will call selection sort function
argument as arr comma n
then we will try to print this so c out
sorted
array
and we will call the function print
array
to print this array
arr comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using selection sort
algorithm
let's get back to our slides let's get
started with what is a binary heap
it's a complete binary tree with all
levels completely filled except the last
level
where all leaves are to the left as far
as possible
a binary heap can be either min heap or
max
maxi
in a min binary heap the elements at
root must be minimum among all elements
present in the binary heap
max binary heap is like minhee where
root must be maximum among all elements
now let's discuss implementation of heap
sort
first
we will start with creating a max heap
of elements present
next up we will remove the elements at
the root and put it at the end of the
array and put the smallest element at
the root
after that we will reduce the height by
one
finally we will repeify the root element
again and repeat the process from step
two
now let's try to implement this
algorithm in the code editor we will
start by creating a function to epify a
subtree rooted with node i which is an
index in array arr
and n is the size of the heap
so void
heapify
i
now we will initialize largest as root
so end
largest
is equals to i
now we will define the left and the
right subtree so end
l is equals to
2
into i
plus 1
and
end
r is equals to
2 multiply
with i
plus 2
now if the left child is larger than
root
then if
l is less than n
and
arr
at l
error at l is greater than arr
at largest
so
the largest
will be equals to l
now if
right child is larger than the largest
so far
so if
r
is less than n
and
arr at r
is greater than arr
at largest
so largest
is equals to r
now if largest is not root so if
largest
is not equals to i
we will swap
arr
at i
with
a arr
at largest
and then we will recursively call ep5
for the affected subtree
error comma
and
comma largest
now we will write the main function to
do heap sort
so void
keep sort
and
arr
bracket comma
and
n
now we will start by building heap
so for
and
i is equals to
n by 2
minus 1
where i is greater than equals to 0
at i minus minus
we will call heapify
for a r comma n comma i
now we will one by one extract an
element from the heap
so for
and i
is equals to n minus 1
where i is greater than 0
at i minus minus
now we will move current root to end so
swap
error
at zero
to a r
at i
and we will call max epify on the
reduced heap so he p5
error
comma i
comma
zero
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
and array
and
arr
comma and n
so for
and
i is equals to zero
i less than n
plus plus i
we will do c out
arr
bracket i
is
and a c out
and l
now let's write the code for the main
block
so
end
arr
is equals to
a comma
18 comma 12
comma
14 comma
5 comma 6 comma
2
now we will write a statement to find
the size of this array so end
and it's equals to
size of
arr
divided by
size of
the first element of the array
arr0
now we will call heap sort function so
heap sort
for arr
comma n
now let's print this
array so see out
sorted
array
is
print
array
at arr comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see our sorting function is
working flawlessly
now let's get back to our slides
till now we have discussed the binary
heap and the algorithm of heap sort
now let's discuss some applications of
heap salt
first up
it can be used to sort a nearly sorted
series of data
next it can be used to find minimum or
maximum elements of the series with ease
also it can be used to solve problems
which requires some sort of priority
let's get started with what exactly is
divide and conquer algorithm
a divide and conquer algorithm
iteratively divides a problem into two
or more sub problems of the same or
relative type until they are simple
enough to be solved directly the
subproblem solutions are then integrated
to solve the original problem
there are three steps involved in the
divide and conquer principle that is
divide
conquer and combine
the first step is to divide the
significant problem into smaller sub
problems
the second phase is to conquer the
solutions to all divided sub problems
then the final step is to combine and
merge all of the solutions to create a
definite solution
we will understand this by an example
right here on my screen
suppose we have a large problem we can
use divide and conquer technique to
divide it into n number of sub problems
such as problem 1 problem 2 problem 3
problem 4 and so on until we reach the
problem n
then we conquer all the solutions to the
specified sub problems as solution 1 2 3
4 and so on and finally we match all the
solutions to get one definitive solution
now that was divide and conquer
algorithm followed by that let us get
into merge sort algorithm
so merge sort is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithms it is based
on divide and conquer strategy merge
sort continuously divides a list into
numerous sub-list until each sub-list
contains only one entry then merges all
those sub-list into a sorted list
there are four elements on my screen
we have seven and three in the left half
and five and two in the right half after
dividing the four elements in half we
combined all the items in ascending
order that is 2 3 5 and 7.
in the next segment we are going to
understand how it happened and we are
going to learn the working procedure of
merge sort algorithm
there are two approaches to implement
the merge sort algorithm the first
method is top down approach and the
second method is bottoms up approach the
first method that is the top done
approach implies that it begins with the
large picture from then it's broken into
smaller chunks
now the second method that is the
bottom-up technique which starts with a
specific number of jobs and works its
way up to the general
let's have a look at how to implement
the merchant algorithm using top-down
approach the top-down merge sort
approach is the methodology that uses a
recursion mechanism it starts at the top
and proceeds downwards splitting the
array into two halves making a recursive
call and merging the results until one
gets to the bottom of the array for a
better understanding of the top down
approach method
consider the following scenario right
here on my screen we have an example of
an array of size 6 consisting of
elements 7 3 9 5 6 and 4 starting with 0
and ending with 5.
using the following formula we'll divide
the array by its middle that is middle
is equals to left plus right divided by
two
we have three elements on the left and
three elements on the right near the
middle so according to the drop down
strategy we divide the given array in
half resulting in three elements that is
7 3 and 9 on the left and 5 6 and 4 on
the right next we sort all these
elements in ascending order by doing so
the first half will be 3 7 and 9 and the
right half will be 4 5 and six and after
merging all of them we will have the
sorted array that is three four five six
and nine
next we will understand the bottom sub
approach
an iterative process is used in bottoms
up merge sort approach it starts with a
single element array and then joins two
neighboring items while also sorting
them
the combined sorted arrays are combined
and sorted again only until one single
unit of the sorted array elements
remains
now let us look at an example right here
on my screen in the first iteration we
will merge pairs of array sizes by one
sorting each of the two elements
when you iterate the array by size one
the elements seven and three become
three and seven similarly nine and five
become five and nine and finally six and
four become four and 6.
we will merge the pairs of array size by
2 in the next iteration with the bottoms
up method as a result the elements 3 7
and 5 will become 3 5 and 7 and the same
way 9 4 and 6 will become 4 6 and 9.
in the last iteration merge pairs of
array size by 3 so that after sorting 3
5 7 4 6 and 9 becomes 3 4 5 6 and 7 as
sorted arrays after understanding the
working procedure of merge sort
algorithm we will now see the pseudo
code of merge sort algorithm
we have a function called merge sort in
this pseudo code and parameter of the
function contains an array named as
array and two variables named as left
and right
if the number of elements in the left is
greater than the number of elements on
the right we will get a middle using
formula left plus right divided by two
the merge sort is called and this
function
now has an array a left variable and
right variable by calling merge sort we
have array left as middle plus one and
right variable and finally by calling
merge sort we have left middle and right
variables in our upcoming segment we
will implement the merge sort method in
a practical demonstration
in the next section we will discuss the
complexity of merge sort algorithm
first we will look into the time
complexity of merge sort algorithm as we
all know time complexity in data
structures is divided into best case
average case and worst case the best
case of merced algorithm is big o of n
into log n average case of merced
algorithm is big o of n into log n and
the worst case of merced algorithm is
big o of n into log n
the number of elements being sorted is
given by n merge sorts time complexity
is big o of n star log n in all three
situations that has worst average and
best because it always divides the array
into two halves and merges the two
halves in linear time
it takes up the same amount of space as
the unsorted array as a result it is not
a good idea to use it to search big
unsorted arrays moving on to the space
complexity of the merced algorithm the
space complexity of the merge sort
algorithm is large o of n
in the merced algorithm we store the
left and right parts of the merged array
in the temporary arrays and then utilize
the original array to keep the entire
merged array in the worst case scenario
the left and the right sub arrays will
each be n by 2 in size and then the
total auxiliary space will be big o of n
resulting in a space complexity of big o
of n
following that we will look into several
applications of the merge sort algorithm
so the first application is merge sort
is an efficient way to sort link list in
big o of n log n time
subsequent application of the merge sort
algorithm is for linked lists merge sort
implemented without taking up more space
followed by that the mod start method is
used to count the number of inversions
in a list
last application states that in internal
sorting the merge sort is employed
now let us look into some of the
drawbacks of merge sort algorithm
so some of the drawbacks of merge sort
algorithm are for smaller assignments
merge sort algorithm is slower than the
other sorting algorithms for temporary
array the merge sort technique requires
an additional memory space that is space
of big o of n
now let us look into a practical
demonstration of merge sort algorithm on
my screen we have an example for merge
sort algorithm
to define constants or micro
substitution we use the hash defined as
preprocessor directive with a constant
variable max of 10. following that two
arrays array 1 and array 2 are declared
we declare array 1 and initialize it
with elements like 8
4 and 1.
array 2 is used for temporary array then
to implement the merge sort concept we
declare a merge sort function we specify
three variables in this function
parameter that is left right and middle
the left variable is used to display the
left part of the array1 the right
variable is used to display the right
part of the array1 and middle variable
is used to indicate the middle or center
of the array in this function
we utilize the for loop in this function
setting the left 2 level 1 the middle
plus 1 to level 2 and
the left to variable i with the
condition that level 2 is less than or
equal to the middle and level 2 should
be less than or equal to the right of
the array
we have a condition in this for loop
that if level 1 of array 1 is less than
or equal to level 2 of array 1 we will
initialize all the consecutive elements
of level 1 of array 1 to array 2. else
we will initialize all the successive
elements of level 2 of array 1 to array
2.
out of for loop all subsequent elements
of level 1 of array 1 will be
initialized to array 2 until level 1 is
less than or equal to the middle all
successive elements of level 2 of array
1 will be initialized to array 2 until
level 2 is less than or equal to the
right of the array
using the loop which will run from i
equal to the left of i is less than or
equal to right we initialize all the
items of array 2 to array 1. we have
declared one more function in this code
namely sorting out of the merging sort
function in which only the left and
right variables are defined we specified
the middle function in the sorting
function with the condition that if the
left is less than the right the middle
will be calculated as left plus right
divided by two then we called the
sorting function passing left as middle
as right and then
another sorting function passing left as
middle plus one and right
finally we use the merge sort function
passing left middle and right to the
sorting array 1 otherwise we will return
nothing
we entered the main function out of the
sorting function where we declared the
counter variable i and printed the array
before sorting using the printf function
in follow
where i will run from index 0 to the
array's maximum size after that we
invoked sorting method
passing left as 0 index number and write
as the iris maximum value
finally after doing the merge sort
process we will print the array using
the printf function and for loop
we will run
from 0 to the array's maximum value then
we compile the program and run it
now let's try to quickly execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the list
before sorting is 8 7 6 2 3 five nine
ten four and one and the list after
sorting is one two three four four five
six seven eight nine and ten let's get
started with an introduction to quick
sort a quick sort is highly efficient
sorting algorithm and it is based on
partitioning an array into smaller sub
arrays and then we will sort these two
resulting sub arrays in the same manner
this algorithm is quite efficient for
large size data sets as its average and
worst case complexities are big o of n
square
now let's discuss algorithm of quick
sort
let's say we have an array first we have
to select a pivot
we can select either the first element
or the last or medium or any random
element as pivots
this pivot will dissect the array into
two sub-arrays
then we will shift all smaller elements
then the pivot element to the left
then we will again apply the same
operation for the left sub array
and take pivot like we did for the main
array
we'll perform the same for the right sub
array as well
we have now introduced the quick sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap so void swap
int
star
x
comma
and
star
y
temp
equals to
star x
star x is equals to star y
ry is equals to temp
now we will write a function which will
partition this array this function will
take the last element as pivot
and the pivot element at its correct
position in sorted array and places all
smaller elements
to the left of the pivot and all greater
elements to the right of the pivot
so int
partition
and
arr
comma
end
low
comma
and i
so end
pivot
equals to
arr high
now end
i
is equals to
low minus 1.
so for
end
j is equals to low
j
less than equals to high minus 1
a plus plus
now if current element is smaller than
the pivot
so if
arr at j
is less than pivot
then we will increment the i
then we will swap
ampersand array
i
comma
ampersand array
at j
and we will swap
ampersand
array at i plus 1
comma
ampersand
array
at high
and then we will return
i plus 1.
now we will write the main function that
implements quick sort
so void
quick sort
and
arr
bracket
comma end
low
comma and high
so if
o
is less than high
and
pi
is equals to partition
arr comma
low
comma
hi
now we will separately sort elements
before partition and after partition
so
quick sort
arr comma
low
comma
pi minus 1
and
quick sort
arr
comma
pi
plus 1
comma hi
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
and
array
and
arr
comma
and
size
and
i
so for loop
i is equals to
zero i less than size
a plus plus
c out
array
layout
and
now we will write the main block so end
array
and comma seven
comma eight
i will find the size so int n
is equals to
size of
array
is divided by
size of
array
element at zero
now we will call quick sort
for array a
comma 0
comma
n minus 1
now we will print this so c out
sorted
array
print
eric
err command
now let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted our array
in this session we will be discussing
the bucket sort algorithm in data
structures
so the bucket sort algorithm divides the
unsorted array into several groups known
as buckets so each bucket is sorted
using any suitable sorting algorithm or
recursively applying the same packet
sort algorithm
i know it's a little complicated to
understand so let's go through an
example
so on my screen we have an example of an
array consisting of numerical elements
that is 12 6 37 29 11 35 21 and 22
now we will create some buckets with
different ranges
so here we have different buckets
ranging from 0 to 7
8 to 15 16 to 23 24 to 31 and finally
the last bucket with range 32 to 39
so 6 will be stored in the first packet
followed by that 11 and 12 will be
stored in the second bucket followed by
that we have 21 and 22 stored in the
third bucket followed by that we have 29
in the fourth bucket and finally the
last two elements which are 37 and 35
stored in the last bucket
in the next stage all the elements are
sorted according to an order that might
be ascending or descending in our case
we have the ascending order so the final
result will be 6 11 12 21 22 29 35 and
37
so this is how the bucket sort algorithm
works in real time now the next topic
that is working off a bucket sort
algorithm in a detailed way
so now we know the briefing of a
pakistan algorithm now let's learn the
working of bucket shot algorithm in
depth
suppose we have an array consisting of
decimal values or floating values as the
input so the first element is 0.47
next we have 0.39 0.23
0.55
0.29 0.41
0.59 and finally 0.31
then we will create an array of size 10
and store 0 in each block
and each block of an array is used as a
bucket for sorting the elements
next we have step 2.
insert the elements into buckets from
the array and all elements are inserted
as per the range of the bucket
packets ranging from 0 to 1
1 to 2
2 to 3 up to n minus 1 to n here
n is the number of elements in an array
so for our example 0.23 will be
multiplied by 10
which is the size of an array and that
gives us 2.3 approximately equal to 2.
so finally we will insert 0.23 into the
bucket number 2.
in exact we will insert other elements
into other respective buckets
followed by that we have step 3
elements of each bucket are sorted using
the stable sorting algorithms
and finally the step 4. in step 4 all
the sorted elements of each bucket will
be gathered and represented in the form
of an array as sudo code is an informal
programming description that does not
require any strict programming language
syntax similarly we will understand it
effortlessly so in the pseudocode first
we will create n empty packets
next we will insert all the array
elements into buckets by multiplying the
size of an array we have to keep doing
this for every array element as we
understood this in working of the bucket
sort algorithm after that we have to
sort individual buckets using insertion
sort and finally we will concatenate all
the sorted buckets next we will learn
about the complexities of bucket sort
algorithm
first we will see about time complexity
so talking about the time complexity we
usually have three cases to summarize
the time complexity so first we have the
best case
so that the best case is o of n plus k
next we have the average case that is o
of n into n and finally we have the
worst case that is o of n
here n is the total number of elements
to be sorted and k is the number of
packets so let us understand all the
three cases one by one so first we have
the best case
so the best case occurs when all the
elements are uniformly distributed in
the bucket with an equal number of
elements in each bucket if insertion
sort is used to sort the bucket sort
algorithm then overall time complexity
is o of n plus k
o of n complexity is for making the
buckets and o of k complexity is for
sorting all the elements after
understanding the best case now we will
see how the worst case occurs in the
bucket sort algorithm
the worst case occurs when there are
elements of close range in the array
they are likely to be placed in the same
bucket
it makes the complexity depend on the
sorting algorithm used to sort the
elements of the buckets complexity
becomes worse when all the elements are
in reverse order and if insertion sort
is used for sorting then time complexity
becomes o of n into n and lastly we will
learn how the average case occurs in a
bucket sort algorithm the average case
occurs when the elements are randomly
distributed in the array it occurs even
when the elements are distributed in
uniform way bucket sorts run at the
linear time
the average case holds true until the
sum of bucket sort sizes is linear and
in the total number of elements
next we will see about the space
complexity
so the space complexity of all the
buckets algorithms is o of n plus k
lastly we have stability so talking
about stability so yes the bucket sort
algorithm is stable after understanding
the complexity of bucket sort algorithm
now we will compare the bucket sort
algorithm with other algorithms
so first we will compare the counting
sort algorithm
bucket sort can be worked as a
generalization of counting sort
algorithm and if each bucket has size 1
then the bucket sort degenerates to
counting 0.
the variable size of buckets or
algorithm allows it to use o of n memory
instead of o of m memory where m stands
for the distinct value that gives
counting sort o of n plus 1 worst case
behavior
next we will compare the buckets or
algorithm with quick sort
bucket sort with two buckets is a
practical version of the quick sort
where the pivot value always selects the
median value of the value range another
meaning of choosing the pivot in quick
sort such as a randomly selected pivot
makes it more resistant to clustering it
in the input distribution
after that we have the merge sort
the n-way merge sort algorithm starts by
distributing the list into n sub list
and sorting each one then the sub lists
created by merge sort have overlapping
ranges and cannot be recombined by a
simple concatenation bucket sort
lastly we have one more sorting
algorithm that is radix sort for
comparison
top down radix sort can be a particular
case of bucket sort where both range of
values and the number of buckets has
contained the power of two
this approach can accelerate the scatter
phase since we only need to examine each
element's prefix of bit representation
to determine a bucket
at last we have one more topic to learn
that is the applications of packets or
algorithm
the bucket sort algorithm consists of
two main applications
first by using bucket set algorithm
input is uniformly distributed on the
range and second by using bucket sort
algorithm there are floating point
values
now let us go through a practical
demonstration of bucket sort algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
packet sort algorithm so we will begin
with the header files followed by that
we will define a function namely bucket
sort algo
this particular function is to implement
a bucket sort algorithm in the functions
argument there will be an array namely
arr and a variable num which will store
the number of elements in an array after
that we will define two counter
variables which are i and j and declare
one more array namely array 1 with the
same size of an arr array
so this particular second array will be
used for displaying all the elements in
the array 1 we will have a for loop
which will run from index 0 to the
entire size of an array and for this
array we will use the variable i as the
counter variable
we will have another for loop to print
all the repeated numbers with frequency
in an array
we will run another value from index 0
to the last element of both the arrays
and elements of array and array 1 will
assign to arr array
now we will execute from both the loops
and now we will enter into the main
function where we will declare an array
namely array with the size of 100 and
two variables which are num and i
next we will ask the user to enter
several elements of an array using
printf function
and now the user will enter number of
elements and we will scan that using the
scanf function
now we will ask the user to enter the
elements of an array using printf
function and the entered elements will
be scanned using the scanf function
and next we will print a before sorting
and an array after sorting using for
loops by calling the packet.algo
function and in this function we will
pass the name of an array that is an
array and the size of an array that is
num
now
let us try to execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed now let us try to
enter the number of elements that is
five now let us enter all the five
elements
two three
one four and five
so the array before sorting was two
three one and four five then the array
got sorted using packet sort algorithm
and the resultant array is one two three
four and five in ascending order
in this session we will discuss the
counting sort algorithm
so without any further ado let's get
started with an introduction to counting
sort
a counting sort is a sorting algorithm
that sorts the elements of an array by
counting the number of occurrence of
each unique element in the array the
count is stored in an auxiliary array
and the sorting is done by mapping the
count as an index of that auxiliary
array
now let's discuss the counting sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will find the largest element
in this array to evaluate the range of
the elements
then we will create a count array to
store the count of element from the
array
then we will update the count arrays
element with a cumulative count
at last we will output each element from
the array followed by decreasing its
count by one
we have now introduced the counting sort
and its algorithm
now let's try to implement this
algorithm in the code editor
let's start by creating account sort
function
void
count sort
its argument as int arr
comma int n
we will declare
an array
output
size 10
and an array count
again with the size 10
and an integer variable max
is equals to arr at 0.
now we will write a for loop to find the
largest element of this array
so for
end i is equals to 1
i less than n
i plus plus
if
a r
at i
is greater than max
then max
will be equals to
arr
at i
now we will initialize the count array
with all zeros
so for
and i is equals to zero
to i less than equals to max
plus plus i
count
at i
is equals to zero
now we will store the count of each
element in this array so for loop
and
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
count
at arr bracket i
is plus plus
now we will write a for loop to store
the cumulative count of each array so 4
and
i is equals to
1
where i is less than equals to max
at i plus plus
count
at i
is equals to plus equals to
count
at i
minus 1
now we will find the index of each
element of the original array in count
array and place the elements in the
output array
so for
end
i is equals to n
minus 1
i
greater than equals to 0
i minus minus
so output
account
at arr
i
minus
1
is equals to
arr
at i
and
then we will decrease count
arr i
by one
now let's write a function to print this
array so void
print array
so end
arr bracket
comma end
n
so for loop
and i is equals to 0
i less than n
i plus plus
c out
arr
at i
out handle
now let's write the main block
and
arr
is equals to
we will write the element
now let's find out the size of this
array so end n is equals to
size of
array
divided by
size of
that is first element
now we will call the count sort function
arr comma and
now we will print this array so print
array
arr comma n
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using counting sort
let's get started with an introduction
to radix sort
radix sort is a non-comparative sorting
algorithm
it avoids comparison by creating and
distributing elements into buckets
according to their radix
and for elements with more than one
significant digit this bucketing process
is repeated for each digit while
preserving
the ordering of the prior step until all
digits have been considered
now let's discuss radix sort algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will find the largest element
in the array to decide maximum number of
significant digits we will need to
compare to sort this array
we will go through each significant
place and sort the array one by one
first we will solve the array according
to the units place
then we will sort according to the tens
place
and then we will sort according to
hundreds place and so on till the array
is sorted
we have now introduced the radix sort
and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start with the utility function
to get maximum value in this array
so int
get max
with an argument as array arr
comma size
n
we will declare variable
int mx
is equals to
arr at 0
and we will write a for loop
where
i is equals to 1
to i less than n
at i plus plus
if
arr at i
is greater than mx
then
mx will be equals to arr
at i
and then we will return
the value of mx
now we will write a function to do
counting sort of array arr according to
the digits represented by exponent
so void
n
comma and
exp
we will declare an integer array output
and
i
comma
account array
of size 10
where all elements are zero
now we will store the count of all the
elements of the array arr
so for loop
i is equals to zero
from i less than n
to i plus plus
count
error
and i
divided by
exp
modulus of
10
plus plus
now we will change count i so that
count i now contain actual position of
this digit in output
so for
i is equals to 1
i less than 10
i plus plus
count
i
plus equals to
count
i minus 1
now we will build the output array
so for loop
at i is equals to n minus 1
to i greater than equals to zero
and i minus minus
output
count
arr
at i
divided by exp
modulus
10
minus 1
is equals to
arr at i
and now
count
arr
at i
divided by exp
modular
10
minus minus
now we will copy the output array of arr
so that arr now contains sorted numbers
according to the current digit so for
i is equals to 0
i less than n
i plus plus
i
is equals to
output
now let's write the main function that
will sort the arr using radix sort
so void
red x
sort
n
n
now we will do the counting sort for
every digit note that instead of passing
digit number exp is passed exp is
basically 10 raised to the power i
where i is current digit number
so
for
exp
is equals to one
and m divided by
exp
is greater than zero
while
exp
is multiplied equals to
10.
we will do count sort
on arr
of size n
with the xp
now let's write a function to print this
array so void
and array
for
and i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
say layout
array
now let's write the main function
we will declare end arr
bracket
with values
170 comma 45 comma 75
comma 90
comma
802 comma 24
comma 2
comma 66
now we will find out the size of this
array arr
and
is equals to size of
arr
divided by
size of
arr first element
now we will call the radix sort function
and we will print this array
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using radix sort
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up radix sort can be used
on lexographically sortable data
next up radix sort utilizes the count
sort algorithm
next radix sort is done by sorting
elements using significant digits
finally radix sort consumes more memory
space than quick sort
so what exactly is a graph
so a graph is a data structure like any
other data structure example linked list
arrays etc so graph is a little
different from the other types of data
structures such as linked list and
arrays they are linear data structures
whereas graph is a non-linear data
structure that consists of finite sets
of vertices and a bunch of edges
connecting with them
so what are these vertices and edges so
let us understand that a graph is
usually represented by
a set of vertices and edges
so a vertice is the node present in a
graph imagine that you are a group of
five friends so each one of you is
considered as a vertex and the network
connecting you guys is known as an edge
so the overall graph of your people can
be considered as g and it is represented
by vertices and edges set where vertices
is you and the network connecting you
guys is called as an edge
so here you can see it clearly each one
of the friend is called as a vertex and
the network connecting them is called as
an edge and the entire graph is
represented using a set of vertices and
edges
now moving ahead we will understand the
graph terminologies
now at first we have the adjacency
vertices and adjacency edges so what are
adjacent vertices
if there is an edge between two vertices
that is one vertex or one node is
connected to another node directly using
just one single edge then those vertices
are called as adjacent vertices now what
are adjacent edges
if there is one common vertex between
two edges then those two edges are
called as adjacent edges let's imagine
this way let us imagine that we have
three vertexes and
these three vertexes are connected using
two edges so here we have one vertex
which is common between these two edges
so such type of edges are called as
adjacent edges
next we have the degree in an undirected
graph number of vertices adjacent to the
vertex is called as
a degree
next is the path
the path is considered as a sequence of
distinct vertices such that two
consecutive vertices are adjacent to
each other
up next we have the cycle
a path that has only one repeated
vertices are called as first and last
vertices
followed by that we have the work
the term block is self-explanatory a
block is the sequence of vertices and
edges in the graph which is used to
traverse through one vertex to another
vertex now we have entered the next
segment of this particular tutorial
where we will be discussing the
different types of graphs available
so at first we have the finite graph
so what exactly is a finite graph a
graph is said to be finite when the
number of vertices and the number of
edges are in a finite number or in a
countable number
now the next type of graph is the
infinite graph so what exactly is the
infinite graph so the infinite graph is
a typical opposite of the finite graph
so this particular graph will not have
countable number of edges and countable
number of vertices
the image here is an example for a
typical infinite graph
now followed by the infinite graph we
have the trivial graph so what is a
trivial graph
a graph is said to be trivial if there
is only one single vertex without any
edges
so this particular type of graph will
only have vertex that is only one single
vertex not more than one and there will
be no edge if you have just one vertex
then there is no possibility of having
an edge unless if you have one single
loop type of edge which is connecting to
itself
but in a trivial graph we don't even
have that we just have one single vertex
so followed by trivial graph we have a
simple graph
so what exactly is a simple graph
a graph is said to be simple if there is
only one and one edge between each
vertex
so this particular example can be
considered as a simple graph so here
each and every set of vertices have one
single edge between them
now followed by the simple graph we have
the multi graph
so if there are multiple edges between
the pair of vertices then this
particular type of
graph is known as a multi-graph so here
you can see that we have two vertices a
and b and we have two edges connecting
them not one but two but in a simple
graph we were supposed to have just one
edge connecting the vertices so this is
the difference between simple graph and
a multi graph
so followed by multi graph we have a
null graph
so what is a null graph a graph is said
to be null if there are only vertices
and no edges between them so remember
the trivial graph right we just had one
single vertex but no edges but here we
do have multiple vertices but no edges
connecting them so this type of a graph
is considered as null graph
so followed by null graph we have the
complete graph
so what is a complete graph
a graph is called as a complete graph
where each vertex must be connected with
the other vertices using the edges
so the meaning of this particular type
of graph is all the edges are connected
to all the other edges using at least
one single edge so here you can see a is
connected to b d and c all together with
at least one edge and similarly all
other vertices are connected to each
other with at least one single edge
now followed by the complete graph we
have the pseudograph
so what is a pseudograph a pseudograph
is a graph where at least one vertex
will have self looping type of edge so
remember the self loop or self edge we
have discussed in the trivial graph type
so this particular type of an edge where
it connects to itself is called as a
loop or kind of self-connecting edge so
any graph that has this kind of a edge
is called as a pseudograph
so followed by the pseudograph we have
the directed graph
so what is a directed graph
any graph is called as a directed graph
where each edge has a direction
associated with it
so so far we have just discussed the
edges which are connecting to one or the
other vertex but there was no direction
but here you can see that this
particular edge has a direction that is
from b
to a not from a to b it is from b to a
this type of edges which are directing
the traversal of the graph are known as
the directed graphs
now followed by the directed graphs we
have the regular graph
so a graph is a regular graph where each
vertex of the graph has the same degree
now here you can see all the vertices
have the same amount of degree that is
the connection between all the other
vertices so the degree of a is 3 so the
degree of b is also 3 and the degree of
d is c and similarly the degree of c is
also 3
so what i mean to say is all of these
vertices have the same degree that is 3.
now we have the weighted graph
so what is a weighted graph a weighted
graph is where each edge holds some
weight that denotes the traversal cost
through those edges now here you can see
that all the edges have a different
weight the edge from a to b has the
weight 5 and the edge from a to c has
the weight 9
and the h from c to b has 2 and the edge
a 2 d as 8 and finally c 2 d as 7 so all
these values are the weight or the cost
to traverse from a to another vertex
flow so from a to b we have the cost
five and a to c we have the cost nine
and similarly c to d we have seven and
so on
now followed by the weighted graph we
have the connected graph
so what exactly is a connected graph a
graph is said to be connected where each
pair in the graph is connected
followed by a connected graph we have
the disconnected graph so it is a
typical opposite of the connected graph
a graph is said to be disconnected where
each player in the graph is not
connected to each other
now next we have the cyclic graph so a
graph is said to be cyclic if it
contains at least one cycle in a graph
that is one complete traversal
connection so a can be traversed again
from traveling a to c c to d d to b and
b to a again so this type of a graph is
called as a cyclic graph
now next we have the acyclic graph
so it is the typical opposite of the
cyclograph so here it cannot traverse to
a again by traversing from a to c c to d
and there is no connection between d to
b so the complete cycle is not available
here this type of graphs are called as
acyclic graphs
so moving ahead we have the graph
representation
so generally there are two different
ways to represent the graph data
structure
they are using adjacency matrix and
adjacency list
so what is adjacency matrix
so adjacency matrix is a sequential
representation adjacency matrix is used
to represent which nodes are connected
to
which node
if there is an edge between two vertices
then the value of the corresponding
element of the graph is one otherwise
zero if there is any weighted graph
besides then zeros and ones we can store
the weight of the h as that particular
number suppose that there is a
connection between a and b and it is
represented as a weight of 5 then there
is a connection so we will use the
connection as true but we will not
represent it as 1 instead we will use
the weight that is 5 to represent it as
5 not as 1 if there is no weight then we
will represent it as 1 and if there is
no connection then we will represent it
as 0.
now undirected graph representation
so here you can see how we have
represented a graph so there is no
connection between a to a that is there
is no loop so the value will be zero if
there was a loop and if it was
represented with a bit then we could
have written a weight here since we do
not have weight then the no connection
is represented as 0 and a connection is
represented as 1 we have a connection
from a to b so we have represented it as
1 and similarly to a to c so and so on
now directed graph representation
so the simple difference between the
directed and undirected graph
representation is we did not have a
direction in the previous segment but
here we do have directions so
b is connected to a but a is not
connected to b so we will write it as 0
because the control is traversing from b
to a but not from a to b so we need to
take care of the traversal of control so
we are representing 0 and you can see
from d to b we have one connection and
the traversal is in the direction of d 2
b so we will have 1 there so here we
have d and b so we have one so in that
way we
represent the directed graphs
next undirected weight graphs
so this was what we discussed before
instead of zeros and ones we will
represent the weight here so we do not
have a connection between a to a so that
is zero as usual but we do have a
connection from a to b so we have
represented it with a number that
happens to be the weight of the edge
and remember we do not have the
direction here this is undirected
weighted graph now if it were the
directed weighted graph then we could
have seen the direction and represented
the number with the weight
now after this let us look into the
adjacency list
so what is adjacency list
adjacency list is a linked
representation
in this representation we maintain the
list of its neighbors for each vertex in
the graph every vertex of the graph
contains the list of adjacency vertices
area of vertices which have vertices
indexed by each vertex number for every
vertex the array element points to the
linked list of the neighbors of the
vertex so this might be a little
complicated to understand so let us
understand this using an example
so directed graph representation
implemented using linked list
so this is the directed graph we are
using
so you can see that a is not connected
to anything so we have ended the address
of next location as x but b is connected
to a and c is connected to a similarly d
is also connected to a
so that is how we represent the
directed graphs using linked lists
next we have directed graph
representation using array
so a is not connected to anything so we
have represented as 0 and b is connected
to b as well as a so we have 1 there and
c is connected to b
so c is also connected to a so we have 2
there d is connected to a c and b so we
have 3 there
now we have the graph traversal
so graph traversal refers to the process
of examining each edge and vertex in a
graph
graph traversing can be performed in two
ways
the first one is breadth first search or
bfs algorithm bfs starts traversing the
graph from root node and expose all the
neighboring nodes then it selects the
nearest node and explores all the new
nodes q data structure can be used in
bfs algorithm
so the following image depicts the epfs
algorithm working it shows us the
nearest node first then it traverses to
all the other nodes
so followed by bfs algorithm we have the
dfs algorithm that is the depth first
search algorithm dfs starts traversing a
graph from the initial node of the graph
and then it goes deeper and deeper until
it finds the node has no child then
backtrack from the dead end towards the
recently explored nodes stack is used
for bfs algorithms so this particular
gif image can be considered as the graph
traversal which is performed using dfs
algorithms so if you don't know much
about dfs and vfs algorithms don't worry
about that those particular tutorial
videos are added in the description box
below you can go through it and
understand bfs and dfs algorithms in a
much better way
now we will go through some of the
applications of graphs
so some of the major applications of
graphs are used in the
websites google maps and social media
websites like facebook and some security
systems
and also software programming
the crystals algorithm is used to find
the minimum spanning tree for a given
graph but what exactly is a minimum
spanning tree or mst
well a minimum spanning tree is a subset
of graph g having the same number of
vertices as of graph g and ages
equivalent to number of word tises -1
along with these properties it also has
a minimum cost for the summation of all
age weights included in a minimum
spanning tree
if you want to learn more about spanning
trees then please consider watching our
video which you can find in the i button
section right away
now coming back to the crystal's
algorithm the kruskal's algorithm sorts
all ages in increasing order of their
age weights and keeps adding notes to
the tree only if the given age does not
form a cycle also it picks the age with
minimum cost at first and the age with
maximum cost at last
hence we can say that the kruskal's
algorithm makes a locally optimal choice
intending to find global optimal
solution
that is why it is also considered as
greedy algorithm the data structure that
we are going to use for implementing
this kruskal's algorithm is union fine
but now you must be thinking what
exactly is this union find data
structure and how it works
well union find is a data structure that
keeps tracks of element that are split
into one or more than one disjoint sets
where a disjoint set is collection of
two distinct groups or clusters that do
not have single common element the union
find features two important operations
named as find and union
the operation find returns the set or
group to which provided element belongs
basically it constructs a bisection
between the object provided and it's set
whereas the union function joins two
distinct disjoint sets to create a
single subset let's understand how this
data structure works with the help of
real life example
let's say we have some singing magnets
placed on table with a higher magnetic
affinity towards each other all the
singing magnets present on the table are
color coded with sky blue color now due
to the high magnetic attraction the
magnets a to e will form a strong
magnetic field which will cause the
bonding or connection of all these
magnets as a result all these magnets
will be grouped together we will now
color code this set with red color along
with that we'll also call this set as
red
after that the magnet f2i are also
closer to each other thus they will also
form a connection we'll call this set as
green
finally this last set of magnets will
also formulate a connection with each
element inside a group
we will call this group as set purple
all these distinct magnets got
distributed into three different
disjoint sets
but as the magnetic attraction between
these groups increases significantly
hence all these clusters of magnets will
end up connecting with each other this
scenario can be related to the union
function
union function merges different sets
into a single subset where the find
operation helps in extracting the group
of element to which the particular
element belongs
similarly in this scenario a particular
magnet can be traced back to its group
with the help of color code that we have
maintained alongside the magnets
the use of union find in kruskal's
algorithm can be related to this example
while implementing kruskal's algorithm
we are going to maintain three distinct
disjoint sets the first set will store
edge weight values for all ages in a
graph whereas the second set will store
tree hierarchy for a different nodes
the last set will store the ranks for
all nodes included in an msd by using
the union find structure and its
operation we can justify the entry of
each edge into the spanning tree which
we will explain in the implementation of
this algorithm
but let's understand the functioning of
this algorithm primarily
the crystal's algorithm begins with
sorting all edges into increasing order
of their age weights this sorting is
done to include edges with the least
edge weight primarily into the tree
structure after that we'll pick the
first smallest edge and we'll check if
it generate any cycle in the tree
structure or not
if it does not form any cycle then we
will include that edge into our spanning
tree otherwise we will discard it
we will keep repeating this process
until mod of v minus 1 edges are
included into our msd where v is number
of vertices now moving ahead let's
discuss how we can create a minimum
spanning tree using kruskal's algorithm
this given graph gve contains 12 edges
and six vertices and we are supposed to
find out g dash such that the number of
vertices is equal to 6 and the number of
edges is equal to v minus 1 that is 6
minus 1 which is equal to 5
the one more condition that the
formulated structure must abide by is
that the summation of all included edge
weights must be the minimum possibility
for this spanning tree going forward
we'll discuss how we are going to create
mst for this graph using kruskal's
algorithm
the first step that we need to perform
is removing all the loops or parallel
edges from our graph hence primarily
we'll remove these two present loops
the next step that we are going to
perform is arranging all the edges in
increasing order of their weights
the reason behind maintaining the sorted
list is to make sure that the first edge
for insertion is of a minimum cost here
i have maintained the sorted list for
all the edges that are part of our graph
so according to this sorted list the
first age that we are going to insert in
our mst is hef as it has minimum weight
cost that is 2.
the next stage that we have in our
sorted list is hfd it also has an edge
weight equal to 2. hence we'll include
it in our spanning tree
the third edge in our sorted list is hbc
with weight 3. the inclusion of this
edge does not formulate any circle in
our tree structure hence we'll add it to
our msd
the next stage is hcf having the age
weight 3 so we'll include it in our msd
structure
the fifth edge that we are going to pick
is hcd having weight 4 but the inclusion
of this edge inside our spanning tree
will create a loop and the structure
that contains a loop can never be
considered as tree hence we have to
exclude this edge
the next age is hbf and the inclusion of
this age will also generate a cycle in
our spanning tree structure
so we will exclude this age as well
the next age
is hbd
this edge has weight value 6 the
inclusion of this edge can also create a
loop in our structure so we'll have to
discard this edge as well
the next stop is h a b with a weight
value 7.
even though this age has higher weight
value than previous ages but it does not
formulate any cycle in our msd so we'll
include it in our tree structure
by doing that we have generated v minus
1 edges for our spanning tree thus we
won't iterate further in our sorted list
this generated mst has minimum possible
cost for our graph gve which is 70. i
hope that you guys have understood the
msd implementation process using
kruskal's algorithm cause in the next
slide i have a problem for all of you
guys to assess your understanding of
kruskal's algorithm
the graph shown on your screen contains
10 vertices and 18 edges and for this
graph you are supposed to generate a
minimum spanning tree such that it
contains 10 vertices 9 edges and minimum
construction cost
in order to do that you can take out
your pen and paper to draw the spanning
tree structures based on the state that
we have discussed till the time i am
aware that this graph is quite strangely
structured however if you can solve this
problem you will undoubtedly be able to
solve all the difficult problems out
there and of course if you are confused
about any step then you can reiterate
through the session but here i am going
to give you guys a little moment to
figure out your answers
well now that you guys must be ready
with your solution so let's check if it
is true
the highlighted part of this graph is
possible structure for a spanning tree
with minimal cost
by removing all the edges the mst will
look something like this i hope you guys
have got the right answer
on that note let's dive further and
discuss the implementation strategy for
kruskal's algorithm
while implementing the kruskal's
algorithm primarily will generate a c
structure for keeping track of the
source and destination node along with
its weight
after that we'll sort all that edges of
a graph in increasing order of the age
weights
moving ahead we'll create three distinct
sets to maintain notes of a graph their
hierarchy in tree and corresponding
ranks for every node for each insertion
of an age in mst we will update the rank
and parent of each node
if the two nodes have the same parent
node then we will not insert the a
joining them as it will generate the
cycle in tree structure
let's understand all these steps with
the help of an example
this is the graph structure for which
we'll try to generate a minimum spanning
tree using c programming language
as discussed earlier primarily we'll
create a sorted list of all ages in
increasing order of their age weights
the list will contain the source node
destination node and corresponding age
weight for that particular age along
with that we are going to maintain
disjoint sets to carry out union
operation those disjoint sets apparent
and rank and they will include rank
value and parent value for every node in
our graph initially all the nodes are in
their own different sets
hence we'll set their parent values to
-1 also the ranks for these nodes will
be initialized to 0 at the beginning
because we haven't included them in our
minimum spanning tree
having said that let's include the nodes
of our graph in our msd
in upcoming slides we'll traverse
through our list of edges to include
them in our minimum spanning tree
now the first edge that we are going to
check is hdc which have minimum h cost
that is 1.
in order to insert this edge in rmst
we'll need to find the absolute parent
of node d and c as well so let's check
out the parent set to determine the
absolute parent value of node d and c
the parent value of node d is -1 and
parent value of node c is also -1
both of them are having same ranks which
means either we can make note d point to
c or node c point to d
here i'll assume that node d points to
node c
so if node d is pointing to node c then
the parent of node d will become node c
and as
c becomes the parent of node d the rank
of node c will change
remember whenever two disjoint tree
structures are joined together then the
rank of one being pointed to will
increase by one
hence the rank of node c will become one
now
once the disjoint sets are updated the
union operation will generate the link
between node d and c
now we'll process the second edge in our
list that is
age cb having weight 2. primarily we
will check the parent values of both
these nodes node b and node c have
parent values minus 1 and minus 1
which indicates that these nodes are
absolute parent of their own sets
since they have different absolute
parents we can join both of them
however the rank of node c is higher
than node b thus the connection should
point from node b to node c
as node b
if pointing towards node c thus node c
will become the parent of node b as well
hence will update the corresponding
absolute parent values for them
next up is hba with the weight value 2.
now the parent value for node a is minus
1 and the parent value for node b is c
so both of them have distinct parent
value which implies that we can
establish a connection between them for
that purpose we'll have to update the
rank field
and as the parent of node b is node c
the rank of c will definitely increase
by 1.
once the fields are updated the edge
will get included in our msd
on that note we have generated our
minimum spanning tree but you must be
thinking about how our algorithm will
discard the other ages
so to understand that we'll traverse
further in our list of edges
the next age is age ac and the parent of
node a is node c itself hence we'll
discard this node as well
now the final age in our list is h80 and
again both these nodes have the same
parent node thus we'll discard this node
as well
now you must be thinking about how we
can limit iteration of the whole list if
we formulate mst using the few topmost
edges only well the answer to that is
pretty straightforward we can avoid the
complete traversal of the list by using
looping condition from e is equal to 0
to e is equal to mod of v minus 1
when we use this condition the looping
will stop when v minus edges get
included in our msd
now the next up is the time complexity
analysis of kruskal's algorithm the time
complexity of kruskal's algorithm will
be big o of e log e plus e log v
the e log e for sorting all edges and e
log v for finding the age from maintain
three sets
the average time complexity graph for
this implementation will be something
like this it will be a parabolic nature
i hope that you all have understood the
strategy for implementing kruskal's
algorithm
so without wasting any time further
let's visit the code editor to develop a
program in c programming language for
kruskal's algorithm
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now to begin with coding implementation
the first thing that we'll do is will
create a storing system to represent a
weighted age
for that purpose we'll use structure in
the c programming language so
let's get started with that
struct
edge
and inside this structure
will create end
source
destination
and
weight
now what we'll do is we'll utilize this
structure to store the edges of the
graph moving ahead we'll also initialize
the structure for storing the complete
graph
so let's create one more structure
and we'll name the structure as graph
and inside this graph structure will
create
node
will also create variable e
to represent number of edges in our
graph
we'll also call the reference of
structure h to this graph by doing this
we'll be able to include all the edges
into our graph structure as well so
let's create that reference
struct
h
star
h
now we have successfully created the
structure for graph
now moving forward what we'll do is
we'll assign dynamic memory to the
reference of graph structure
for that what we'll do is we'll write
code struct
graph
star
generate
graph
and inside this function will pass
and
node
and
the number of
edges
that is e variable
now
we'll write body
for this function
and inside body
first thing what we'll do is we'll
create
the space
that is dynamic memory space for this
graph structure
equal to struct
graph
star
malloc
size of
structure
graph
next
graph
dot
node
will be equal to node
and
graph dot number of
edges
will be equal to
e itself
next
what we'll do is
we'll allocate a memory to each edge
okay
underscore here
for that what we'll do is we'll use
struct
h star
malloc
size of
struct
age
and finally
will return
the
graph
now we have successfully allocated
memory space to our graph and individual
edges as well
so moving forward what we'll do is we'll
initialize one more structure to store
the parent array and rank array
basically these are the disjoint sets
whose usage will allow us to generate a
spanning tree using union find algorithm
so let's get started with that we'll
create another structure
and we'll name this structure as
tree underscore
maintainance
underscore set
and
inside this structure
will create
parent array
and
rank array
now we have created the tree maintenance
set structure so let's generate an union
find algorithm for maintaining msd
structure
in order to do that let's create a
function named find disjoint set first
so
this find this joint set function will
be of end data type
find
underscore
disjoint
set
and inside this will pass
struck
tree
underscore
maintenance
underscore set
let's object
subsets
and
a variable int i
inside this function will use if case to
find root and make it as a parent of
argument i
also if it is -1 then we'll need to
update it for that we'll keep recurring
through this a block by calling the
function find disjoint set inside a
block so
let's do that if
subsets
i
dot
parent
is not equal to
i
then what we'll do is
will
get inside this f block and will execute
subsets
i
dot parent
is equal to
find
underscore
disjoint set
and will again pass same argument
subsets
comma
subsets
i
dot
parent
and finally
we'll get out of this pip block
and
will return
subsets
i
dot parent
now we'll create a function for union
operation let's name this function as
void
union
underscore
disjoint
set
and insert this will pass
struct
tree
underscore
maintenance
underscore set
and its object
subsets
and will pass
argument x
and argument
y
now inside this function will create two
variables named x root and y root
and the x root variable will store the
return data from find disjoint set when
the x has been passed to the function
and similarly the y root will store the
return value for find this joint set
given y as an argument so
let's write command for that
and
x root
will be equal to
find
disjoint set
and objects will be subsets
comma
x
similarly
and
y root
will be equal to find
disjoint set
and object subsets
and
variable y
now in order to build connection between
these nodes
as discussed previously the node with
lowest rank value should always be
pointing to the node with highest rank
value and vice versa so we'll have to
use this a block in order to put this
condition in the connection building
block of our program so we'll write
condition for that here now
if
subsets
exude
dot rank
it's greater
less than
subsets
y root
dot rank
then what we'll do is
we'll set
subsets
x root
dot parent
to y root
that means
oh okay
so what we are doing here is we are
checking the rank value of x root
if the rank value of x root is smaller
than y root then what we'll do is we'll
simply set the y root as parent of x
root
i hope you guys are clear with this now
moving forward we'll write lc part of
this condition
else f
subset
x root
dot rank
sorry
i'll have to add s here
and f subsets x root dot rank is greater
than
subsets
y root
dot
rank
then what we'll do is
we will
set subsets
y root
dot parent
is equal to
x root
otherwise
if both above mentioned condition fail
then what we'll do is we'll add one more
condition
we'll set subset
y root
dot parent
to
x root
and then
we
set subset
x root
dot
rank
to incrementation
there is one mistake over here
subsets okay
so
now we have implemented the union find
algorithm
for this crystal's implementation
next we'll create a function to sort the
list of edges in our graph according to
increasing order of their 8 weights
so let's create new function for that
will name this function ads
and my
comparator
and inside it will pass
const
void
star
a
and
const
void
star
b
and
we'll create function body
but before we get started with coding
implementation of this mycomparator
function
i want to talk about arguments of this
function so basically a and b are
constant quantifiers
the significance of this quantifier is
to tell the user that you cannot modify
this pointer and the location it is
pointing to throughout the program
so
let's
get started with
the coding part of this my comparator
function
what we'll do is
we'll create
struct
h
star
a1
is equal to
struct
h
star
a semicolon and similarly
struct
h
star
b1
will be equal to
struct
h star
b
next we'll return the output
a
1
dot weight
it's greater than
b1
dot weight
so basically what this statement will do
is if the weight value of a1 is greater
than b1 then it will return a1 as output
and if the weight value of b1 is greater
than a1 then it will return b1
i hope you guys are clear with this my
comparator
function
so moving forward will finally create a
crystal mst function
the return type of this function will be
void
and we'll name this as crystal mst
and inside it will pass argument
struct
graph
star
graph
and we'll create function body
now the first thing that we'll do here
is we'll assess the value of number of
nodes in a graph and after that we'll
generate a new reference of structure
age for storing our msd so
the first thing we'll
get
the node
to
graph
dot
node
and
struct
h
result
node
along with it will also initialize
variable e
and variable i equal to zero so end
e
is equal to zero and end
i
is equal to
zero
we need to break the indentation here
and here as well
and semicolon so basically these
variables will store index values for
result and index variable for the sorted
list simultaneously
now moving forward
we'll sort all the edges of a graph
if we are not allowed to change the
given graph then we can create a copy of
the given graph
the function named q sort allows us to
do that so let's create that q sort
function here
q sort
graph
edge
comma
graph
e
comma size of
graph
h
zero
so this q sort is nothing but c standard
library function that implements a
polymorphic sorting algorithm for arrays
of arbitrary objects
according to a user provided comparison
function
and that comparison function is nothing
but this my comparison function and
i guess
you guys must be clear with this q sort
term
so let's add
comma here
and we'll give call
to a
my comparator function
now moving forward we'll break the
indentation
and
we'll call
the object of tree maintenance set
underscore
maintenance
[Music]
set
star
subsets
equal to
start
tree underscore
maintenance
underscore
set
star
malloc
node
star
size of
struct
tree underscore
maintenance underscore
set
and we'll add
semicolon here
so next we'll create subsets equal to
number of nodes and after that will make
sure that all the elements have the rank
value equal to 0
and to do that we'll initialize new for
loop
so
let's
create for loop here
we'll begin it from v is equal to zero
to
v
is less than
node
and
we will set this way
to incrementation
after that
make body for this for loop and inside
it
will set
subsets
v
dot parent
is equal to
v
and
subsets
v
dot
rank
is equal to
zero
now moving further
will traverse through all the edges in
the graph but we want to limit our
traversal to the number of vertices
minus one and to achieve that will
create while loop here
while
e
is less than node
capital node
then
node minus one
and and
i
it's
smaller than
graph
a
then
create struct
h
next underscore h
equal to
graph
dot
h
i plus plus
and here
will create
x and y nodes
so
let's do that and x
will be equal to
find
underscore
disjoint set
and will pass subsets
comma
next h
dot source
and
for y
will pass
find underscore distance sets
subsets
comma
next underscore h
dot
destination
now if including the h between x and y
does not create the cycle in our graph
only then we can include that edge in
our msd for that what we can do is we'll
set if
x
it's not equal to
y
then
will set
result
e
plus plus
equal to
next
underscore edge
and
we'll find unions
disjoint set
for
subset
and
will pass x and y as well
with this we have successfully created
our kruskal semestre
function now what we'll do is we'll also
print the structure of our minimum
spanning tree for that we'll need to
create pattern using printf function so
let's do that
the first statement that will print on
screen is edges
created
in
mst
are
ads below
and we'll add backslash and so that our
output gets to the next line
we'll add semicolon
and
to that
will add end
minimum
cost
variable
and we'll initialize it to
zero so
okay
so
what we'll do is
we'll create for loop here
and we'll initialize it with iterator
element beginning from zero
till
i
less than equal to e
and one
i create this i element
and
what we'll do is
we'll create pattern
for printing the edges the pattern will
go like modulus d
dash dash
modulus d
equal to equal to
modulus
d
slash ends
and
the parameters that will get printed
will be
result
i
dot
source
comma
result
i
dot
destination
and
result
i
dot
weight
okay
so we haven't
comma here
now this error will get resolved
now after this
what we'll do is
we'll increment this minimum cost
variable by adding the values of edges
to it
so
we'll take this minimum cost variable
and
we'll add
result
i
dot
wait to it
now we'll get outside this for loop
and
will printf one more statement
the cost
for
creating
mst
is
modulus
d
and
will print minimum
cost
okay we have now
successfully
implemented kruskal's algorithm function
and we have created code for printing it
on console as well
so now moving forward will work on our
driver method
and for that let's
get into its function body
here
first we'll
define the number of nodes that we are
going to use for our graph
those number of nodes
are
four
the graph structure that we are going to
pass to this crystal's algorithm program
is the same that we have discussed
implementation strategy for
it had four edges
and it also had
six
edges as well
so
we'll add six edges here
now what we'll do is
we'll set
struct
graph
star
graph
equal to
generate
generate
crop
we'll pass node
comma
e
and we'll add semicolon
now next
we'll create graph structure by
implementing the edges
so the for
first h
will call graph
dot
h
zero
dot source
will be equal to zero
that means
the
first age will begin from zero
and
it will
end at
destination
node
and that will be
one
and the weight
for this
age will be
equal to
2.
now we'll copy this
pattern
and
we'll paste it below
okay
and now
the h
will be one
and for this
h1 the source will be 0 and destination
will be 2
and the weight value will be 4.
now
let's copy this again
paste it
and we'll set
age number to 2.
we'll change source
and destination now source will remain
same and destination will be changed
we'll make it 3
and the weight value will also remain
the same
that means
h between 0 to 2 and h between 0 to 3
have same
age weight
now
for next
ctrl v
we'll remove this indentation
and now
we'll change
the node number age number
here
the source will be 1
and destination will be
3
and the age weight value
will be 3
after this
we'll add new
h
the age number will be 4 now
the source will be
2
and destination will be
three
and
age weight would be one
and
the last
age will be
h
five
and
the source
will be
1 here
and
destination will be 2
the age weight will be
2. now after this what we'll do is
we'll give call to a critical msd
function
in order to generate minimum spanning
tree and will pass this graph structure
to it
and we'll add return zero statement
with this we have successfully completed
a programming implementation for
kruskal's algorithm
so let's run it and check if our code is
working fine or not
okay so we are getting three problems
here
the first one
is expected token oh
so
and
node will be equal to
and this node should also be capital
here
okay
so what
next error is there
yeah
so now a code is bug free
oh
but some exception is happening here
we'll jump this exception will try to
jump it
okay but we are not having any errors
into our system so
i think that's the compatibility issue
with our vs code
so let's copy this code and paste it
into the virtual coding environment and
will check it if this code is working
fine or not
so
we'll copy the code
and we'll go back to the google chrome
we'll
go to the online compiler tool
and here
we'll paste our code
and we'll run it
okay
so here we are getting our output so
there will be only three edges that will
get form in our minimum spanning tree
and the cost for all those ages will be
5.
i hope this coding implementation is
clear to all of you out there
if you are concerned about this code
then don't be as we can send it over to
you if you drop your email ids in the
comment section below so drop your email
ids in the comments section below in
order to receive this code
backtracking is an algorithmic method of
alternately
solving a problem
to explain the issues it employs a
recursive approach
backtracking is required to find every
possible combination to solve an
optimization problem
backtracking is used in solving various
problems like n queens knight store the
rat in the maze problems and so on
now to get better understanding of
backtracking let's have a brief look at
and queen's problem
let's say we have four by four matrix
we have to place four queens in that
every row and column has exactly one
queen and none of them falls under the
same diagonal
we will start with the left most column
then we will check our base condition
that if we have placed all the queens or
not
now we will try every row in this column
if we found a location where the queen
can be safely placed then we will mark
it as a part of an answer
and then we will recursively check if
placing queen here will lead us to the
solution or not
if yes then we will return true
otherwise if false then we will
backtrack and try other rows and repeat
these steps
if all rows have been tried and nothing
worked then we will return false to
trigger backtracking
now let's implement this end queen's
problem in the code rater
we will define a vector
inside a vector
it will be a end vector
result
now we will write a utility function to
check if the queen can be pleased on
board
so
it will be a boolean function
bull is safe
as argument we will place a vector
inside a vector
and
board
comma
and
row
comma
and
column
will define
end i comma j
and
n
will be equals to board size
now we will check if this row on the
left side
so
for loop
i
is equals to zero
i less than column
i plus plus
f
or
at row
i
then we will return
now we will check upper diagonal on left
side
so for
i is equals to rho
comma j
is equals to column
j greater than equals to zero
and
i
greater than equals to zero
i minus minus
comma
j
minus minus
if
bored
i
comma j
then return
now we will check lower diagonal on left
side
so for
i equals to rho
comma j
is equals to column
i
less than n
and
j
greater than equals to zero
i plus plus comma j minus minus
now f
code
at i
and j
will return
else we will return
basically what we have done in this
function is we have checked that row and
the right diagonal and the left diagonal
so that no queen can overlap
now
next
we will write a recursive utility
function to solve n queen's problem
so
pull
its argument will be vector
inside a vector
enter
ampersand board
comma and
column
now we will first check our base case if
all queens are placed
so int
n is equals to
board
size
f
m
is equals to n
then we will define a vector
and
p
so for
and
i is equals to zero
i less than n
and i plus plus
another nested for loop
and
j is equals to zero
j less than n
j plus plus
if
board
at i
j
is equals to
1
then
v dot push
back
j plus one
now
we will print result
start
push back
and we will return
true
now we will consider this column and try
placing this queen in all rows one by
one
so
boolean
plus
is equals to false
now for
loop and i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
now we will check if queens can be
placed on board i
can call them call
so if
is safe
bored
i
know
if it's safe then we will
place this coin at the position so board
i
call
is equals to
1
now we will make result true if any
placement is possible
so
res
is equals to
solve
and cube
at
board
comma
call
plus one
or
rest
now if placing queen in board i call
doesn't lead to a solution then we will
remove the queen from the board i column
and backtrack
board
now if queen cannot be placed in any row
in this column
then we will return false
so
return
yes
now this function solves the end queen
problem using backtracking
it is basically using solvency to solve
the problem
it returns false if queen cannot be
placed otherwise returns true and print
placement of queens in the form of once
now there may be possibility that there
are more than one solution
then this function will print one of the
feasible solution
vector
ida vector
and queen
and
n
result
dot
clear
now we will call vector
inside a vector
board
and
comma
vector
and
bracket n comma zero
now if
solve
enqueue
at board
comma 0
is false
and we will return
empty set
otherwise
we will sort
result
dot begin
comma
result
part
and
and we will return
result
now we will write the main block
so
n is equals to
4
so for
vector
inside vector
and
v will be equals to n queens
at n
so we will write for loop
auto
ar
v
we will call c out
then for loop
auto
atr
ar
c out
itr
and see out
and then we will return 0.
now let's run this code
as you can see we are getting two
answers
now this end queen can be solved with
both of these answers
now let's get back to our slides
last let's sum up what we have learned
in this session
first up backtracking is simple to
implement and has fewer lines of code
most backtracking codes are composed of
few lines of recursion function code
next
since we use recursion the function
information is stored on the stack which
has high space complexity
next when the branching factor is
significant it is very time consuming in
many cases
finally many problems such as knight
stewart
and queens rat in the maze subset some
problem and so on can be solved using
backtracking choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
we will have a look at an application of
the spanning tree to understand it
better
meet patrick patrick works as a head of
the network administration department in
an i.t solution company named as gray
solutions
being the head of network administration
department patrick is responsible for
managing his team to keep the
organization's computer network up to
date and operate it as intended
network administration department
coordinates and connects multiple
systems in the company to a single
network using multiple routers
this network is called as local area
network or lan which is created for the
sole use of an i.t company
but in the last few days something went
wrong in the network management system
which came to patrick's notice he
observed that the network loop is formed
in a routing system a network loop
occurs when multiple routes carry
information from the same source to
various computing devices
and due to this formation of a network
loop the network connectivity started
slowing down initially after a few hours
the network connectivity completely went
down and all the operations of the
company stopped abruptly
now patrick and his team needed to do
something in order to resolve this
problem permanently
so patrick started brainstorming to find
out an optimal solution to fix this
problem
one of patrick's teammate was good at
data structures and he came forward with
an idea to implement a spanning tree
data structure for managing the routing
connections
he suggested replacing the old naive
routing strategy with a minimal spanning
tree routing
after listening to this idea the whole
network administration team started
working on implementing a spanning tree
while doing that they treated the
network connection as a graph the
routers and end devices like computers
fax machines were treated as the nodes
of the graph where the connecting wires
carrying network signals were treated as
the edges of a graph
but before understanding how patrick's
team was able to solve this problem
using a minimum spanning tree let's
first understand the basics of this data
structure
this will allow us to get a clear
insight into how spanning tree solves
network routing problems
so let's start with graph and its
different types
basically a graph is a structure made of
nodes and edges connecting them and
there are three types of these graphs
based on the types of edges
the first is the undirected graph the
second is the directed graph and the
last is the connected graph
let's understand these types completely
in the upcoming slides
the first type of graph that we are
going to discuss is the undirected graph
it is termed as a graph in which all the
edges does not point to any specific
direction in simpler words all the edges
of this graph will be bidirectional
as you can see in this particular graph
you can move from any node to any other
node and retrieve back as well
next up is the directed graph it is a
graph in which the edges point to a
specific direction
by this i mean in this type of graph you
can only move towards a single direction
for example you can traverse this given
graph starting from a then b
then c
then d and finally e
but here you cannot traverse back from e
to a as this graph is unidirectional
the last type of graph depending on its
edge is a connected graph
it is defined as a graph with a path
from any vertex to any other vertex in
the graph
in this particular type of graph you can
reach any vertex from any other vertex
in a graph for example you can go to
node b or d from node a and arrive back
at a from either vertex b or d
now moving ahead we will understand what
a spanning tree is and how we can create
it
mathematically the spanning tree for any
graph g having vertices v and edges e
can be represented using superscript
notation g dash having vertices v dash
and edges e dash
suppose we intend to create a spanning
tree for graph g then our spanning tree
g dash must follow few constraints
the first constraint suggests that the
number of vertices for created spanning
tree must be equal to the number of
vertices of a given graph g
further the edges of g dash should also
be similar to the number of vertices in
graph g minus 1.
to understand this mathematical
formulation clearly let's have a look at
an example
now for this given graph g we have to
formulate all possible spanning trees
remember a single connected graph can
have multiple spanning trees until we
fulfill the constraints mentioned
earlier
so for this particular graph g we have 5
vertices and 5 edges
additionally each edge has been assigned
with some cost or weight
let's say this weight represents the
distance between the connected two nodes
to create the spanning tree g dash we
need to ensure that g dash contains 5
vertices and 5 minus 1 that is 4 edges
hence for this graph we can create a
spanning tree like this
you can observe that we have eliminated
one node in the spanning tree to remove
the loop or cycle in a graph
for this spanning tree one we have a
cost or value equal to 10
and this cost is nothing but the
summation of all edge weights
now that we have created the first
spanning tree for our graph g i would
like to ask all of you to give this a
try
for that i am going to provide you with
a short moment to generate all possible
spanning trees for the structure that we
are discussing right now
you can also pause this video if you
need more time in order to do that
so now let's have a look at all possible
spanning trees at a glance we have seen
that the value for the first spanning
tree was 10
and for this new spanning tree 2 it is
13. in this spanning tree the edge
between vertices b and c is removed
the next spanning tree looks something
like this with cost 14.
further we have spanning tree number 4
with a value 12.
and finally we have the last possible
spanning tree 5 with a value 11.
out of all these spanning trees the
value or cost for spanning tree number 1
is the least which is 10.
thus this spanning tree will be called
as minimum spanning tree
i hope you're clear with the creation of
spanning trees but how can we judge the
number of all the possible spanning
trees
well for that you need to check the
structure of your graph
if the graph you have been given with is
cyclic then the number of possible
spanning trees will be equal to the
number of vertices
the cyclic graph is a graph in which you
will have the same number of vertices
and edges with a cyclic structure
if the given graph is a complete graph
then the number of possible spanning
trees will be equal to v raised to v
minus 2
where v is the number of vertices in a
given graph
you can say that the given graph is a
complete graph if each pair of vertices
is connected by the unique edge
for this particular graph the number of
possible spanning trees will be equal to
the number of vertices that is 4 to the
power of 4 minus 2 which is further
equivalent to the square of 4. hence the
number of possible spanning trees for
this structure will be 16.
moving forward let's understand some
important properties of spanning tree
we have already gone through some
crucial properties while creating
spanning trees in the previous section
so primarily we will list all of them
here the first property of a spanning
tree conveys that a connected graph can
have more than one spanning tree
the next property states that the number
of vertices and spanning trees must be
equal to the number of vertices in the
given graph whereas the number of edges
is equivalent to the mod of v minus 1.
the third property of a spanning tree
says that the spanning tree must not
contain any cycle if the structure that
you have created as a spanning tree
includes a loop or recycle then it's
clear that you have made a mistake
because no tree can contain a cycle
and finally the fourth property is all
about kayley's formula if the given
graph is a complete graph then you can
calculate the number of possible
spanning trees using the formula v
raised to b minus 2.
the next property of a spanning tree
conveys that a spanning tree can never
be disconnected
for example if you create a spanning
tree for this given graph which is
accurate
and you erase one edge
when you do that the structure will no
longer be a spanning tree it can only be
referred to as a disconnected graph the
next property states that if the graph
contains more than one similar weight
there is a possibility of having more
than one minimum spanning tree for
example in this particular graph there
are more than one edge having the same
weights
thus there will be two possible minimum
spanning trees with the same cost that
is seven
this is all about the properties of
spanning trees
now that you understood what spanning
tree is you would have also understood
how it proves is an effective solution
and that is exactly how patrick from our
story solved his network issue
in a few days patrick and his team
changed the knives routing into the
minimum spanning tree routing now the
routing parts are managed by a minimum
spanning tree to maintain cost
effectiveness
and to avoid any looping activity
as we have already understood misty
removes all the loops from a given graph
and we also know that the whole network
becomes the graph for which msc will
maintain a minimal routing path hence
the network system will never experience
a network loop again
due to this amazing initiative patrick
and his team were appreciated by the
whole organization
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of a spanning tree and why it
is one of the most important algorithms
in data structures
now we will look into the different
applications of spanning trees
the first application that we are going
to talk about is telecommunication
network building
if we want to build a telecommunication
network for the whole city and we are
putting different connection lines for
each customer then we will have to deal
with a huge cost this naive ordinary
approach is not the best solution to
build a connection line
but no worries this problem can be
resolved using the minimum spanning tree
data structure in this case each
customer will be treated as a vertex
whereas the connection line will be
treated as an edge
the minimum spanning tree will give us
the possible output for generating the
telecommunication network
no matter what type of algorithm you are
building using machine learning
techniques somewhere down the line you
will be using clustering techniques
quite liberally
clustering and data preparation go hand
in hand as many times you will be
working at least initially with data
sets that are largely unstructured and
unclassified
those data sets cannot be classified
using single neuron or classification
methods
so you use a clustering algorithm which
utilizes a minimum spanning tree to
create clusters or groups by mapping
distances between data points
the next application of a minimum
spanning tree is image segmentation
you must have observed that your face
gets detected with the square shape
while clicking images in selfie mode
this scenario is happening due to the
image detection algorithm developed on
the camera system
at the backend the picture gets
fragmented into tiles of similar pixels
with the help of a minimum spanning tree
the last application of the spanning
tree is its use in calculating the
finance factors
a correlation matrix can be created by
calculating a coefficient of correlation
between any two stocks
this matrix can be represented
topologically as a complex network and a
minimum spanning tree can be constructed
to visualize the relationships
so what exactly is breadth first search
algorithm so breadth first search
algorithm visits every node efficiently
and marks all the nodes which are
adjacent to that particular node the
critical nodes in the graph are in a
breath wise manner
breadth first search starts traversing
from root node and then selects all the
unvisited adjacent nodes of the selected
node
queue data structure is used to
implement bfs algorithm so here you can
see a gif which is explaining about bfs
algorithm so let us consider that we
have selected the root node as 1 then it
will check for all possible adjacent
nodes so it will traverse to 2 then it
will traverse to 3. after that it
doesn't have any adjacent nodes so the
control moves to either one of the child
nodes that is 2 or 3 so let us consider
that we go to 2 and from 2 it will check
for all the adjacent nodes that is 4 and
5 and there are no other adjacent nodes
from 2 then it will go to 4. it can also
go to 5 but here let us consider that it
goes to 4 so from 4 it does not have
anything to traverse so it get backs to
2 then it goes to 5 and from 5 it checks
for the traversal there is only one
possibility that is seven and no other
explorations then it goes to seven and
there is no other possibility for seven
as well so it comes back to five then to
two then to one and then it enters the
second child node that is the three from
the 3 it moves to another possibility
that is 6 and it checks for another
possibility but there is no possibility
so now the control moves from 3 to 6
from 6 it tries to visit the adjacent
nodes so 6 has only one adjacent node
that is 8 and no other adjacent nodes
and now from 6 it goes to 8 and from 8
it checks for any other adjacent nodes
but there is no other adjacent node so
it gets back to 6 then 3 then to 1 back
so this is how the control traverses
when you are implementing breadth first
search algorithm
now here let us look into an example for
breadth first search algorithm as
discussed in the previous example here
the root node is selected first then it
goes to b
then it goes to c
and it checks for any other adjacent
node but there is no other adjacent node
other than b and c so the control moves
to b and from b it starts traversing to
all its addition nodes first it
traverses to d then to e and it checks
for any other possibility but there is
no other possibility so the control goes
back to b then to a and from a it
traverses to c and from c it checks for
all the adjacent nodes that is f and g
so it checks for other possibilities
since there is no other possibility it
goes through f and from f it checks for
other possibilities but there are no
other possibilities from f so the
control gets backs to c and then finally
to g and in g it checks for any adjacent
nodes since there is no adjacent node
from g it stops there and we have the q
output here that is a b c d e f and g so
this is how the breadth first search
algorithm works now to understand this
in a practical way let us try to execute
a program in dev c plus plus
so now we are on dev c plus plus and the
program on my screen is an example for
bfs algorithm
in this program we have a queue first as
bfs is executed using queue data
structure
and there are two variables that is rear
and front and there is one array named
as size and the size is defined here as
50.
next we created some functions first
there is a queue function to create a
queue then we have nq and dq to insert
and delete the element from the queue
so this is the enqueue function and this
is the dequeue function to insert and
delete the elements from the queue
then we have a function to display and
after that we have the empty function to
check whether a queue is empty or not
so this particular code segment is to
check whether the queue is empty or not
and this particular function is the
print function which is used to print
the elements inside the queue
after that we defined node and made a
function as creating a node and in node
there is a one variable named as vertex
and one pointer next to it
so this is the structure for creating
the node
and followed by the node we have created
another structure called graph and
inside graph we have the create graph
function to create the graphs and we
have number of vertices adjacent lists
and visited
and next we have the add edge where we
will add edges in between the vertices
and finally we have the bfs algorithm
so here we will check if the queue is
empty or not first then we will call the
dq function and we will execute
the bfs algorithm
and now finally we have the main
function where we will add all the edges
to the graph and call the bfs algorithm
now let's try to run this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the output is
displayed on the screen
so q contains
the values that is 0q reset node is
visited to 0
and then q contains values 2 and 1 now
the node is visited to 2 followed by
that the queue has values 1 and 4 and
node has visited 1 and then q contains
values 4 and 3 and node has visited the
value of vertex 4 and finally queue
contains value 3 and the queue is reset
and the node is currently visited at
node number 3.
now with that let's move ahead into the
next type of algorithm that is the depth
first search algorithm so what is depth
first search algorithm
so dfs algorithm is used for traversing
trees using the depth wise direction
the execution of this algorithm begins
with the root node and explores each
branch before backtracking
next dfs uses stack data structure to
remember to get a subsequent vertex and
start a search whenever a dead node
appears or the dead end appears at any
iteration
now we used to have cues in bfs
algorithm but in dfs algorithm we will
be using stacks now to understand the
working of depth first search let's go a
bit more detail
so here we have a graph so how depth
first search algorithm works
now here we can choose the root node
first so once the root node is chosen it
sees the possibilities of traversal it
starts from the left side tree first it
first visits b and now it will not stop
at b
in bfs it used to stop at b and used to
check all the possibilities but here it
is not like that it will first visit b
then it will not stop at b it directly
sees the depth of the b that is it has
another child node so it will enter the
left child node and checks d and now
here it will not stop at d it will check
for possibility side t so since there
are no possibilities from the left or
right side of d it will get back to b
and now it will check for another
possibility from b that is right side
first it finishes the left subtree on
completion of left subtree only then it
will enter the right subtree so here it
checks for the possibility it found e
and from e it will check for another
depth search so there is no depth search
from e and not on left and not at right
so it comes back to b
from b it visits the root node again
from here it checks for the right
subtree now here we have c so it will
not stop at c it will go to the next sub
tree that is f
and now it will not stop at f it will
search for other opportunities now since
there is no other opportunity or other
vertex from f it gets backs to c and
after that it checks for next right
subtree that is g so from g it looks for
another opportunity or vertex since
there is no other vertex it gets back to
c then to a
so to keep the traversal in order
it uses stack data structure
now for a better understanding let us go
through a practical demo on dev c plus
plus and now we are on dev c plus plus
and this particular cone is an example
for dfs algorithm in this particular
code we have defined the structure that
is node and inside the node structure we
have this vertex and node reference
which points to the next node in the
graph
followed by that we have the graph
structure and inside graph structure we
have the number of vertices and visited
and referenced to each node
followed by that we have the depth first
search algorithm
and this particular code segment is the
logic for depth first search algorithm
then we have the structure
of node reference and followed by that
we have the structure of graph reference
that is the number of vertices visited
and the adjacent vertex list and then
the reference if that particular node is
visited or not now we are using dynamic
memory allocation here and followed by
that we have add edge function where we
will add edges between the vertices and
followed by that we have the print graph
function so here we will be printing the
stack data structure which has the
vertex after visiting all the vertices
in the graph and finally we have our
main function where we will assign the
edges to the graph then we will call the
depth first search algorithm
now let's try to execute this code and
see the output
there you go you can see that the code
got successfully executed and we have
our list here that is we have visited
the
vertex 2 3 1 and 0.
now followed by this let us look into
the differences between breadth first
search and depth-first search algorithms
so some of the fundamental differences
are breadth first search finds the
shortest path to the destination whereas
depth first search goes to the bottom of
the subtree and then backtracks
the next difference is bfs algorithm
uses a queue to keep track of the
following locations to visit whereas dfs
algorithm uses stack now we have gone
through that in the examples for both
dfs and bfs
followed by that the next difference is
the bfs uses fifo that is first in first
out order of implementation because we
are using queue data structure here
whereas dfs uses lost in first out order
of implementation because we are using
stack data structure
the next difference is bfs requires more
memory as compared to dfs and depth
first search requires less memory
compared to that of bfs
followed by that
we have bfs algorithm which gives the
shallowest path to the solution next
compared to bfs dfs algorithm does not
guarantee for shallowest path as the
solution
the next difference is in bfs algorithm
if you do not find any goal then you may
need to expand to the other nodes before
the solution is found whereas in dfs if
you do not find any goals then the
backtracking will start from the leaf
node now we will discuss some of the
major applications of bfs algorithms
so bfs algorithm can be easily used to
create the shortest path and the minimum
spanning tree to visit the graph
vertices in the shortest time possibly
with high accuracy
bfs algorithm is implemented to locate
all the neighboring nodes in
peer-to-peer network and this will find
the required data faster
search engine or web trawlers can
quickly build multiple levels of indexes
by employing bfs algorithm and start
implementing from the source and then it
visits all the links from the source
the bfs algorithm guides the broadcast
packet to find and reach all the node it
has for the address now we will look
into the applications of dfs
the next application of dfs is it is
primarily used for scheduling jobs for
the given dependencies among the group
of jobs in computer science it is used
for instruction scheduling data
serialization and compilation task
ordering
next the dfs algorithm can be easily
adapted to search all solutions to a
maze including nodes in an existing path
in the visited set the breadth first
search approach repeats the procedure
for all the nodes until the desired node
is found
the queue data structure is the data
structure that is used for breadth first
search algorithm
for a better understanding we look at an
example of breadth first search
algorithm the blue color indicates that
the node has been already explored while
the pink color indicates that the node
has not been explored yet or visited yet
next we'll have our output
we will use a queue data structure to
keep track of all the nodes visited and
all the nodes that are unvisited
so to begin let's look at the algorithm
as a result we'll have node a which is
added to the output and marked as
visited we must verify all the unvisited
addition nodes of a that is node b and
node c and add b and c nodes to the
output and enqueue to the queue
according to the breadth first search
algorithm
then we'll look at any node between b
and c we'll start with node b node d is
unvisited adjacent to node b so we'll
add node d to the output and q and since
node b is now being visited we'll
dequeue it
when it goes to node b the next
unvisited note is node e add node e to
the output and nq to the dq once node d
has completed its traversal dq from the
queue
now in the case of node e the adjacent
node is node c
which is already visited thus we will
dequeue node c from the queue
now that the pointer is pointing to node
c and node f is the next unvisited node
after the node c we will set node f to
output and q
here the pointer leads to node f which
has no unvisited adjacent nodes so we
will dequeue f from the queue and queue
is empty so we'll come to the halt here
here's what we got that is a b c d e and
f
after understanding all the theoretical
aspects of bfs algorithm let's look at
the code of bfs algorithm in c
programming language
now we are on the practical mode on my
screen you can see an example for bfs
algorithm
we have declared a two dimensional array
with maximum row and column size of 10
and two arrays the first one is a square
of a maximum size of 10 and the second
one which is a visited that stores the
maximum size of 10 as well
some variables n i j and finally we
declared front which is initialized with
0 and rare variables which is
initialized with -1
we perform a loop from index 1 to the
size of an array visited in this
function with the condition that if two
dimensional array of column 1 and
visited array of index is not 1 we
initialize variable i to the front of
the queue then one is set as the front
of the queue index of the visited array
and we use the breadth first search
function
with the vertex as the front of the
queue until front is less than or equal
to rare then we enter the main function
where we define the variable x that
stores the graphs vertex and then we use
the printf function to enter the number
of vertex that will be stored in
variable n
then we perform loop from index 1 to
queue size and visited array in which we
initialize 0 to the queue and index 1 to
the visited array then after that we'll
enter the graph value in the form of
matrix of two dimensional array by
performing the loop with two variables
i for the graph row and j for the graph
column
then we print the source node which is
saved in the variable x
then we print the source node which is
saved in the variable x and we call the
breadth first search function or method
which takes a vertex x as parameter and
we print which nodes are reachable by
looping from index 1 to the size of the
visited array if index 1 of the array is
visited otherwise breadth first search
is not possible so this was the
explanation of the program now let's try
to execute and see the output
there you go the program got
successfully compiled and now it's
asking for the input now it is asking
for the number of vertices let's enter
the number of vertices as 3.
now it is asking for us to enter the
input in the form of matrix so the first
row will be
1
2
and three so these are the first rows
the next rows will be two
three
and four
so the last row elements are three four
and five so we have successfully given
all the three rows of elements now let
us select the
source node so the source node would be
2. now all the nodes that are reachable
from the source node 2 are 1 2 and 3.
so there you go that's how you implement
the breadth first search algorithm so
what is a depth first search
so basically a depth first search is an
algorithm for traversing or searching
the tree or graph data structures the
algorithm starts at the root note
selecting some arbitrary node as the
root node in case of graph and x plots
as far as possible along each branch
before backtracking
so dfs starts with the initial node of
the graph then goes deeper until it
finds the goal nodes or the leaf nodes
or the nodes that have no children that
is the end part here you can see 4 and 7
are the leaf nodes so the depth first
search algorithm runs till the end of
all the nodes that is 8 10 all these are
the
leaf nodes are the last gold nodes
in dfs the backtracking starts once all
the nodes are explored
and the dfs algorithm uses stack data
structure for its traversal now that was
a brief introduction to the dfs
algorithm now for a better understanding
let's go through a practical example
so here we have a graph data structure
with elements a b
c d
e and f so we will be running the dfs
algorithm and we will be traversing
through all the nodes of this particular
graph and the traversal will be recorded
using a stack data structure and we have
two different colors which will be used
to indicate the element's color
so the black color is for the nodes
which are not visited yet and the blue
color will indicate the nodes which are
being traversed already
now this is the stack data structure
that we will be using for the traversal
and we have another part which declares
or which gives out the output of the
traversal of the nodes of this
particular graph
now we will begin with the first one
that is a now followed by that we will
move ahead to b
then after b we will go through d
then after d we have e next we have c
and last we have f
so that's how we traverse through the
graph using the dfs algorithm
now for a little more understanding
let's go through a practical example
where we will be executing a program for
implementing the dfs algorithm
so this particular program on my screen
is an example for dfs algorithm so here
we have the structure node
so followed by that we have also the
methods which will create the edge
and which will also print the graph
elements and finally we have the main
class now don't worry about the code
this particular code segment or the
complete code document will be added in
the description box below and you can
have access to it and try to run it on
your local system and have a better
learning experience now without further
ado let's try to run this program and
get the output and see how the dfs
algorithm gets implemented and traverses
through the graph
there you go the program got
successfully executed and we had the
graph elements that is 0 1 and 2
and 3 so it has visited all the elements
that is 2 3 1 and 0 according to the
stack data structure and we have found
the output over here in this session we
will discuss shell sort
shell sort is a sorting algorithm that
is based on insertion sort algorithm and
it is very efficient when the smaller
value is on the far right and must be
shifted to the far left then this method
avoids significant shifts as in
insertion sort
now let's discuss the algorithm of shell
sort
let's say we have an array we will
initialize a variable h
this edge will represent intervals
then we will divide this array into h
intervals it will create some sub arrays
then we will apply insertion sort on
these sub arrays
after that we will reduce the interval
edge by one
then we will repeat this process
recursively until h counts down to one
we have now introduced shell sort and
its algorithm now let's try to implement
this algorithm in the code editor
first we will start within function to
sort an array using shell sort
so int
cell sort
we will write argument as end
arr
bracket
comma
and n
we will start with a big interval then
we will reduce this interval by 1
so
for loop
and
interval
equals to n by two
interval
greater than zero
interval
divide equals to 2.
now we will do a gap insertion sort for
this interval
so for
and i is equals to interval
i is less than n
i plus equals to one
and is equals to
ar packet i
now we will shift earlier gap sorted
element up until the correct location
for ar i is for
so hint
a
so for
k is equals to i
and j greater than equals to interval
and then
arr bracket
j minus interval
greater than temp
and j minus equals to
interval
now arr
at j
is equals to arr
j minus
interval
now we will put this temp in its correct
location so arr
bracket j
is equals to
temp
now i will return 0.
now let's write a function to print this
array
so void
n
so for loop
and
j is equals to zero
a less than
n
j plus plus
c out
arr
bracket j
now we will write
the function for the main block
so end
arr
is equals to
12 comma 34
comma 56 comma
85 comma
2 comma
9
comma 11
comma
5.
now
let's find the size for this array so
int n
is equals to
size of
array
divided by
size of
first element of this array
now
see out
array
array
before
so
now print
array
arr comma
and
sort
arr
comma n
now c out
erase
after
sorting
we will again print array
here
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted
this array
here we will look into the real-life
example of greedy algorithm in order to
understand it better this is alex he's
quite wealthy and intelligent as he
works for one of the most reputed it
firms and this is alex's best friend
rachel rachel is in dire need of 85
right now
however she needs money in such a
quantity that the number of coins is
kept to a minimum so rachel shared this
issue with alex and asked him for help
now alex is thinking about rachel's
issue which he can easily fix because he
has a limitless supply of fifty dollars
twenty dollars ten dollars and five
dollar coins stashed in various bags
although this being said alex needed to
think about the constraint rachel told
him about he needed to give her money
such that the number of coins utilized
must be minimal to do so alex began
making a list of the various coin
combinations in which he could present
money to rachel however after a while he
became confused due to the vast number
of conceivable combinations
so he decided to use his programming
ability to solve real life problems
alex developed a program that will
provide him with the optimal number of
coins that he can present to rachel
this generated program was iterating
through the different possibilities to
choose the best solution
at each iteration the program added the
coin of the largest value that was not
taking alex pass the amount to be paid
which is 85 dollars in this case
for 85 dollars the largest denomination
id can start giving is 50
now id is still short of 35 to reach the
amount so that the next largest coin
program can take in as twenty dollars
but since the program still requires
fifteen dollars to meet the threshold
the next highest denomination it can
accept is ten dollars followed by five
dollars
the best part about this program was
that it allowed alex to present 85 in
just four coins which is fairly
incredible
the vital thing to note here is that
after each loop the program makes a
greedy choice providing the coin with
the highest potential value what i mean
here by greedy is that locally optimal
choice is picked at every step to reach
the global optimum solution now moving
ahead we will formulate the idea of
greedy algorithms
basically a greedy algorithm is based on
a problem-solving method that involves
making locally optimal decisions at each
stage in the hopes of achieving a global
optimum
that means at each stage we choose a
locally optimal value in the hopes of
arriving at the optimum possible end
result
furthermore this algorithm is an
optimization technique that can find
either minimum optimum result or maximum
optimum result
the best part about this algorithm is
that it is simple to understand and
implement as well additionally the
runtime complexity for this algorithm is
pretty reasonable
however the fundamental disadvantage of
this strategy is that we only receive
the globally optimum value in a small
percentage of cases
having said that you must be thinking
about when to implement this algorithm
for solving particular problems as it
does not always produce globally optimum
results
well let me tell you guys that we have
two conditions to judge our problem for
implementing greedy algorithms
the first condition is the greedy choice
property this notion states that making
locally optimal judgments can lead to
the global optimum solution for a given
problem
the second condition is about optimal
substructure the problem has an optimal
substructure only if an optimal solution
to the entire problem comprises the
optimal solutions to the sub-problems
in simpler words that means the problem
can be split down into multiple
sub-problems and the solutions to these
sub-problems can collectively lead to a
solution for the entire problem
if both the above-mentioned properties
are satisfied by the problem then we can
create a greedy solution for that
particular problem
moving forward we will look into the
steps for constructing a greedy solution
finding the substructure or subproblem
that can lead us to the final answer is
the first step in building a greedy
algorithm
because in this algorithm we are just
trying to operate with local optima to
reach the global optimum solution
the second step is about determining the
type of solution the given problem can
result into that can be either the
largest sum or minimum path
the final step for creating the greedy
solution is about creating an iterative
process for traversing through local
stages and making decisions to reach a
globally optimum solution
now you might be confused about how we
can do that
well let's go through an example to
understand the approach to implement a
greedy solution
the example that we are going to deal
with is called the traveling salesman
problem in which a salesman is supposed
to reach the destination from a given
current location
the representation of cities and parts
connecting them is done using graph
structure where each node is considered
as a city and edges connecting them as
parts having edge weight as the distance
between the two cities
now in this case we are supposed to find
the minimum path between two cities so
to do that we will begin from the
current arbitrary position
from this node called as starting
location there are three possible paths
but the path towards city b has less
distance hence we will traverse this
edge primarily as it is an optimal local
route
we have reached city b now and from this
node we have two possible parts out of
which one part directly leads us towards
the destination city having distance 20
but the other path leading towards the
city f has edge weight value or distance
value as 2.
hence according to the local optimal
decision we will choose the edge
connecting cities b and f for traversal
we have reached the city f now from this
noro city there is only one path leading
us to our destination
hence we will traverse it now we have
reached the destination city the path
highlighted in the green shade is the
global optimum for this tsp problem
you can verify that by calculating the
edge weights for all other possible
parts
since the solution allows us to reach
the global optimum by making optimal
decisions at the local stage this
strategy to solve the problem will be
considered a greedy approach
now moving ahead we will look into the
demerits of using greedy algorithm
we have learnt that the greedy algorithm
makes decisions based on local optimum
instead of analyzing the broader picture
of the whole data hence there is a
possibility that the greedy solution
might not be the best optimal solution
for some problems
for example consider this travelling
salesman problem
in this problem the highlighted part is
a created solution to reach the
destination city from the current
location using a greedy algorithm
but if you observe this graph the
selected solution is not the global
optimal solution for this problem in
contrast it is the worst generated
solution to reach the destination
that is why the greedy algorithm is
considered to be prone to correctness
issues
even if the algorithm is correct proving
why it is correct is difficult
thus it is deemed to be trickier to
solve specific issues
now we will discuss about applications
of greedy algorithms to understand their
importance
the first application of a greedy
algorithm is its use for constructing
minimum spanning trees
the coding approaches that we use to
generate msds is based on the greedy
algorithm
both prim's algorithm and kryskal's
algorithm are known as greedy algorithms
as they make decisions based on locally
optimal decisions
the next application of the greedy
algorithm is it's used to implement
huffman encoding and decoding algorithms
the huffman coding technique is a
lossless data compression method
the concept is to give variable length
codes to input characters the lengths of
which are determined by the frequency of
the related characters
the smallest code is assigned to the
most frequently occurring character
whereas the largest code is assigned to
the least frequently occurring character
this process is carried out by making
local optimum decisions
hence it is also considered to be a
greedy algorithm
the final application of the greedy
algorithm is its use for developing
solutions to well-known coding problems
those problems are the activity
selection problem job selection problem
and fractional knapsack problem
all these problems generate solutions by
making decisions at each local stage so
the solutions for these problems can be
developed quite easily using the greedy
approach
the prim's algorithm is used to find
minimum spanning tree for a given graph
but what exactly is a minimum spanning
tree or mst well a minimum spanning tree
is a subset of graph g having the same
number of vertices as of graph g and
edges equivalent to a number of vertices
minus 1.
along with these properties it also has
a minimum cost for summation of all age
weights included in a spanning tree
prim's algorithm starts with a single
node and explores all the adjacent nodes
at every state the edges with minimal
age weights causing no cycles in the
graph gets selected hence we can say
that prim's algorithm makes a locally
optimal choice intending to find global
optimal choice that is why it is called
as greedy algorithm
moving ahead let's understand how we can
find out the minimum spanning tree using
prim's algorithm
now given a graph g consisting of
vertexes v and edges e we need to
construct a minimum spanning tree g dash
with vertices v dash equal to v and
edges e dash equal to v minus 1
having the summation of edge widths
minimal
this particular graph g contains 9
vertices and 12 edges that means our msd
g dash will have 9 vertices and 9 minus
1 edges that is 8 edges so with this in
mind let's create an msd for this graph
g using prim's algorithm
the first step in prim's algorithm is to
choose an arbitrary starting vertex
here we'll select node a as our starting
vertex
now the next step in prim's algorithm is
to add new vertices with a minimum age
weight
in this case from vertex a we have two
possible edges for traversal
the age weight for age a b is 1 whereas
the age weight for age ac is 6 so
obviously we'll choose vertex b here
since we have reached vertex b we'll
look into the possible ages for adding
an age with minimum weight to our msd
hbd have the minimum age weight so we'll
add it to our mst
now from vertex d there is only one edge
hence we'll directly add that hdh into a
spanning tree
now from vertex h there are two possible
paths out of which the path hi has
minimum cost thus we'll add it to our
msd from vertex i there is only one edge
so we'll directly include it in rmst now
that i have included vertex g i am going
to check what connected edges i have
from vertex g but since there is only
one edge from vertex g we'll just insert
it on our mst from vertex e two edges
are going to different vertices so we
will choose the one with least age
weight and that age is h ec
now that i have included node c i am
going to examine what connected edges i
have to consider from vertex c
currently out of these two highlighted
edges i want to pick that edge which has
not yet been included in msd and has the
minimum edge weight but the question
that arises here is can i add this edge
ac into our msd
well we cannot if we add hac to our mst
then it won't remain a tree structure
due to the creation of cycle or a loop
which we cannot allow to happen
according to the prem's algorithm thus
in this particular case we'll choose h
cf for insertion in rmst and finally the
summation of age weight for this mst
will become 30.
also till the time you must have
observed that this algorithm chooses the
next vertex that offers the most
prominent or immediate benefit
it started with an empty spanning tree
for maintaining two sets of potassius
the first site was for the vertices
included in the msd and the other one
was for the vertices that haven't been
included in the mst at every step this
algorithm considered all the edges that
connected the two sets and picked the
one with minimum age weight from the
adjacency matrix a group of edges that
connects two sets of vertices in a graph
is called cut in graph theory so at
every type of prim's algorithm we find a
cut of two sets one contains the
vertices already included in mst and the
other containing this rest of vertices
after that we pick the minimum age
weight from the cut and include that
vertex to our msd set that is why this
algorithm is called as greedy algorithm
having said that let's dive into the
implementation strategy for developing
code for prim's algorithm
the idea behind prim's algorithm is
simple all the vertices of a spanning
tree must be connected hence the two
disjoint subsets of vertices must be
connected in order to create a spanning
tree and further this vertices should
only be associated with the minimum age
weight to make it a minimum spanning
tree
in order to store these vertices and
edges we'll create an adjacency matrix
using 2d array in c programming language
well the indexes of this 2d matrix will
be the vertices where the values other
than 0 will be the edge widths
for indexes 0 1 and 2 you can clearly
see that the adjacency matrix is having
value 0
that means there is no recurring
connection or loop for these vertices so
primarily let's add them to our graph
structure
for age 1 to 2
we have the weight value 2 so we will
add edge between
vertex 0 and 1
after that
we have
age between 2 and 1
the value for this age weight is 3 so
we'll add edge between 1 and 2 and
ascend 3 as its age weight
finally the age weight for connecting 0
to 2 is 4 so we'll insert it in our
graph as well in the next slide we'll
discuss the strategy for implementation
of a prim's algorithm
from this example i hope you are clear
with how we are going to maintain a
structure of a graph using 2d matrix in
the next slide we will discuss the
strategy for the implementation of
prim's algorithm
the first step of this algorithm is to
maintain a set for keeping track of
vertices included in an msd once we
create the set we'll assign a key value
to all vertices in the input graph
initially we are going to set all key
values as infinite and at the runtime
we'll assign weight 0 to the first
vertex by doing that we choose it as an
arbitrary starting vertex
once done with that we'll start adding
vertices to our minimum spanning tree
for that we'll pick up a vertex u with
minimum weight to insert it into our set
after that we'll also update the key
values for all adjacent vertices of you
on that note let's visit a code editor
to implement prim's algorithm using c
programming language
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now in order to begin with coding
implementation we'll need to load some
dependencies
for this implementation process we are
going to need a boolean set in order to
keep track of vertices included in our
msd that is why we'll include a standard
boolean library in our program
so
hash include
std
dot h
once done with this addition we'll
define a number of vertices that we are
going to use in our graph i am going to
set the number of vertices to 5
so let's do that
hash
define
vertices
5
and if you want to implement mst for a
larger graph then you must set the
number of vertices to a more significant
number now let's move to the main
function
the graph that i am going to use for
generating a minimum spanning tree is
supposed to be stored inside a 2d matrix
so first let's have a look at that graph
this is the graph for which we want to
develop a minimum spanning tree the
first step that we must take to do that
is converting this graph into 2d matrix
as discussed earlier the diagonal values
will be null or zero and all the values
will be the edge weights between two
nodes so without wasting any time on
this i will directly create adjacency
matrix for this graph inside our code
editor
this part is about maintaining our graph
in form of 2d matrix
now after this
we are calling prim semestic function
which is responsible for generating a
minimum spanning tree so
let's do that here
rims
underscore
mst and we'll pass this
graph
to this function
but we haven't developed any code for
this prims msd function but we'll do
that now
so let's create
prims msd function void
prims underscore mst
and will pass graph as an argument
should be for dices
and vertices
to make it a 2d matrix
now inside this function will create an
array named key to store key values of
all vertices
and key
vertices
along with that we'll also initialize
the parent in which we'll store our
actual mst and boolean set to keep track
of each and every vertex of our graph
so let's create that parent
array
vertices
and we'll create
boolean
set
for maintaining track of all vertices
now after this what we'll do is we'll
set the key values of all vertices to
infinity and we'll also make sure that
these vertices are not part of our
minimum spanning tree set so for that
we'll create a for loop
and inside this for loop we'll use
iterator element i
and we'll initialize this element to 0
till
vertices
and will increase the iterator element i
for each loop
and set this loop
we will set
key i
to the
possible integer maximum value
and in order to
use this value will need to add one
library which is called as limits dot h
so
we'll add it here
hash
include
limits
dot h
okay
after this
we will also make sure that these
vertices are not part of our minimum
spanning tree set or boolean set so for
that we'll write statement mean
underscore span underscore tree
i
should be false that means empty
and we'll add indentation
okay
now in order to choose the arbitrary
index we'll set the key value of our
first vertex to zero so that it will be
chosen first in our minimum spanning
tree for that we'll write statement key
0
should be equal to
0
and as we have chosen vertex 0 as our
first arbitrary vertex so we'll also set
the index 0 of the parent array to minus
1.
by doing this we are ensuring that the
index 0 is the root node of our minimum
spanning tree
now to choose vertices with the minimal
key value will create a new function
named list key
so let's do that
and
list
underscore key
and inside it will pass arguments end
key
boolean set
and inside this function body we are
going to set all key values to infinity
so let's do that
in list
will be equal to int
underscore max
and
we'll also initialize
minimum underscore index as new variable
now using a for loop will traverse
through all vertices if the given
vertice is not present inside the
minimum spanning tree set and the key
value is also smaller than the least
value then we'll set the list variable
to the key value and minimum index to
that particular index fee
so
let's create that for loop
and inside it entry as iterator element
and we'll initialize
end to value 0
and
the maximum limit for this v
will be
vertices
and
we'll increase the value of this small v
variable
plus plus
now
if the chosen vertex
is not present inside minimum spanning
tree set
and and
the key value
for that vertex
is also smaller than list
then
we will set list
equal to
key of
v
and minimum index
to
v
and will get out of this for loop and
will return
the minimum index value
on that node let's arrive back at our
prims msd function
here using a for loop will fetch the
minimum index that we have generated
inside a list key function
so let's create for loop
we'll use count variable here
and we'll initialize it to 0
and we'll
move this count variable
till
vertices
minus 1
which is nothing but the number of
vertices in our minimum spanning tree
next
we'll increase this count variable
now we have arrived inside this for loop
body
now we will store that fetch minimum
index value in variable u
so into u
will be equal to least
underscore key
and will pass
key
and
boolean set that is min
underscore span underscore tree
and
we will include this list node that is u
to our minimum spanning preset
or boolean set
equal to true
now here we'll use a nested loop in
order to insert a complete edge which is
initiating from node 0.
inside this loop we'll further call if
log to validate some conditions
so
let's create that nested for loop first
and
v
is equal to zero
to v
v
plus plus
and inside this for loop
we'll add
f lock
and we'll check graph
u
to v
and and
mean
span tree
v
is equal to equal to false
and and
graph
u
v
it's
minimum than
k of v
then what we'll do is
we'll set
parent
of v
to u
and key
of v
to
graph
you
re
so now you must be thinking about what
exactly is this code is doing
so actually what we are doing is we are
inserting node u into our minimum
spanning tree and once we include node u
into our minimum spanning tree then we
check if there is any age between u and
v
v is nothing but all the vertices inside
the graph if there is h with between u
and v then we check if that v is
included in our spanning tree or not if
it is not included then we check the
value key value of v
if the key value of v is greater then
what we do is we set parent of v is
equal to u
and key value of v is equal to graph u v
which is nothing but the weight between
h u and v
so that's what this code is doing
after this what we'll do is we'll write
one printf statement so for that we'll
need to get out of this for loop
and we'll write printf statement
print f
created
spanning
tree
for
given graph
is
backslash n so that this next part comes
inside the next line
and
will also
make a call
to
print
underscore prim's
mst
function which is not created yet but
we'll write code for it
once done with this call
and we'll pass parent and graph to it
well
now let's
create a code
for this print frames msd function
and
print
underscore prims
mst
and will pass
and
parent
will pass end
graph
with
vertices
and
vertices
now inside this function
what we'll do is we'll write one printf
statement
to
show the pattern of printing
edge
slash t
wait
slash and
semicolon
and in next slide
we'll create iterator element
and we'll initialize it to one
and we'll extend this
till
vertices
and i plus plus
printf
printf
modulus d
dash
modulus d
slash
t
backslash d
modulus d
and backslash n
and will pass
parent
i
comma i
comma
graph
i
and
parent
of
i
this statement will print a graph on our
screen
but here is one mistake
that i have made i haven't added the
indentation for this for loop
okay
i think this should be fine now
we can say that our coding
implementation is finished now let's run
our code and check if it is working or
not
well we have received output on our
console here that means our code is bug
free and it works fine
you can verify this result by drawing
the spanning tree of output on your
notebook and further you can compare it
with the graph that we have shown
previously
furthermore if you are concerned about
this code then don't be as we can send
it over to you if you drop your email
ids in the comment section below
additionally you can also try to run it
on your local system to understand its
minute implementation details and
implications
so with this successful coding
implementation we came to the end of
this video
and with that we have reached the end of
day two so far we have learned the data
structures and algorithms
on day three of software development
learning we'll escalate things and get
started with the whole programming
language and learn the object oriented
programming concepts our programming
language of choice would be c plus plus
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to stay tuned for more from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you